Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 171, 171 und mein Name ist immer noch Tim Pritlove und heute, ja, heute geht es nicht um die Wurst, heute geht es um die Eisenbahn. Das dachte ich mir, wäre ja mal genau das richtige Thema. Eisenbahn ist ja auch gerade wieder ganz hoch im Kurs hier in Deutschland, so in allgemeinen Diskussionen, wobei ich eigentlich noch nie das Gefühl hatte, dass das schon jemals mal anders gewesen ist. Das ist irgendwie offensichtlich Eisenbahn, Züge, das bewegt irgendwie alle. Irgendwie ist das auch so ein Land, was ja auch ein bisschen zugvernarrt ist, ist ja auch irgendwie Teil der der ganzen kulturellen und technikkulturellen Entwicklung und auch von daher natürlich nicht zuletzt deshalb auch ein CRE-Thema. Da ich aber keine Ahnung habe von Zügen, habe ich mir mal hier andere Experten geladen und ich begrüße gleich zwei davon, nämlich auf der einen Seite den Marvin, Marvin Blauth, hallo. Und Hannes, Hannes Sowa. Hallo. Aus Karlsruhe, da bin ich nämlich immer noch hier auf meiner Tour, letzte Station, dann geht's mal wieder zurück auf nach Berlin. Tja, Hannes, Marvin, was habt ihr mit Zügen zu tun?
Eigentlich nicht besonders viel, also bei mir hat so der Spaß angefangen mit Zügen, als ich halt in der Schulzeit noch ziemlich viel gependelt hatte, habe und bin dann irgendwie dazu gekommen, dass es halt nicht so war, dass halt Zugfahren irgendwie so das Fortbewegungsmittel für mich war, sondern es hat mir Spaß gemacht, Zug zu fahren und hatte mich dann irgendwie so ein bisschen auch Internet fortgebildet und darüber gelesen und irgendwann bin ich mit meinem Kollegen Marvin dann an der Uni, haben wir uns rausgefunden, dass es sogar Eisenbahnwesen als Vorlesungen gibt und machen das gerade bei unserem Informatik-Studium als Nebenfach. Eisenbahnwesen, genau, ein unterbereich des Verkehrswesens.
Und was umfasst das so alles?
Das umfasst Betriebsablauf, Steuerung, Sicherheitstechnik, physikalische Grundlagen, Radschiene-Interaktion oder elektrotechnische Bereiche. Genau, bis zum ganzen Betriebswesen, wo es dann darum geht, wie werden Züge, wie können Züge überhaupt fahren, wie ist die Sicherheitslage dann übrigens geregelt, also dass Züge nicht aufeinanderprallen, wie wird ein Fahrplan erstellt, da ist eigentlich eine ganze Wissenschaft eigentlich für sich selbst. Es geht bis ins Rechtswesen hinein, also Aufgabenbereich des Eisenbahnbundesamtes, was muss kontrolliert werden, wie ist es für den Bauwesen kontrolliert und so weiter.
Also eigentlich ist das ein recht spannender, sehr breitbandiger Ausbildungsteil, wo man sowohl Technik als auch Organisationen quasi mitbekommt. Ja, das hat gar kein schlechter Fokus. So würde ich da ja eigentlich auch mal drauf schauen. Ich meine, bei Eisenbahnen kann man natürlich jetzt wirklich unglaublich weit ausholen, aber das will ich jetzt nun wirklich nicht tun. Ich meine, dass früher mal Dampfbrasser durch die Gegend führen etc.
Tun sie auch heute noch.
Es gibt noch Dampf.
Definitiv, also nicht in Deutschland, aber in China ist auch ein Großteil noch Dampf betrieben.
Ernsthaft?
China hat im größten Teil Dampf, aber sie haben auch vorgestern oder gestern 420 kmh schnelle neue Magnet-Shaped-Bahnen in Betrieb genommen.
Ein Land der Gegensätze.
Also, was ich weiß, war letztes Jahr noch mehr Dampf als elektrifizite Eisenbahnen unterwegs in China.
Wann ist das in Deutschland abgewählt worden, das Konzept? Das war doch irgendwie so in den 70ern, oder?
Im östlichen Bereich sind Diesel-Züge auch immer noch moderner. Nürnberghof weiß ich nicht, die wird jetzt elektrifiziert, aber da fahren zum Teil noch... Ich glaube, die letzten Dampfzüge waren in den 70er Jahren, glaube ich auch. Aber generell, die Elektrifizierung ist halt erst dann noch später gekommen.
Ja, okay, also Diesel ist ja sozusagen noch mal dazwischen. Diesel fährt ja auch noch in Deutschland. Genau. Wie ist das eigentlich? Wann wird auf Diesel gesetzt noch? Welche Gründe hat das? Weil man jetzt ein paar Tou-Strecken nicht elektrifizieren will? Oder wie sind das noch irgendwelche Vorteile?
Man hat häufig Nebenstrecken, die einfach aus historischen Gründen dort stehen, wo sich eine Elektrifizierung nicht lohnt aus mangelndem Fahrgastaufkommen. Und wo man auch die Industrie meist verschwunden ist, weil die irgendwie nach China oder sonst wo ausgewandert ist. Aber man dennoch über die Bestandsstrecken weiter nutzen will. Und dort setzt man dann Diesel-Züge ein, weil es halt einfach kosteneffizient ist.
Binniger als dann sozusagen.
Es ist häufig so, dass halt einfach der Staat vorgibt und sagt irgendwie, wir müssen halt diese Ortschaften anbinden. Ihr habt keine Wahl, irgendjemand muss das machen. Und wenn man da nicht jetzt das Geld in die Hand nehmen möchte und in die Infrastruktur investieren möchte, dann macht ein Diesel-Zug auch noch Sinn.
Ja, nachvollziehbar.
Oder wenn halt, was in Deutschland nicht der Fall ist, aber in anderen Ländern, wo man einfach Tausende von Kilometer langen Strecken hat, wo man dann irgendwie einmal am Tag seinen ein Kilometer langen Zug drüberjagt, dann lohnt es sich nicht.
Aber was so die allgemeine Eisenbahnentwicklung geht und so die Mehrheit des Transports, vor allem im Hinblick auf Hochgeschwindigkeit, da führt ja an Strom irgendwie kein Weg dran vorbei. Das ist vielleicht auch das, was man hier mal so ein bisschen mehr in den Mittelpunkt stellen sollte. So dieses Eisenbahn-Realität in Europa, sag ich mal. Vielleicht werden wir auch noch mal so ein bisschen über Europa hinaus schauen. Aber es ist ja auch gerade ein heißes Thema. Aber es passieren ja auch gewichtige Dinge. Also jetzt vor kurzem war ja hier der Durchbruch in der Gotthardtunnelprojekt, wo dann auch Eisenbahnen den Norden und den Süden mit einer Hochgeschwindigkeitsstrecke verbinden werden. Das ist ja auch verkehrstechnisch sozusagen nochmal eine komplett neue Dimension im Vergleich zu dem, was bisher so besteht. Und auch grundsätzlich sieht man ja, wie in Europa neue Stricken und Verbinde geschlagen werden. Immer mit diesem Problem, dass wir ja eigentlich noch mit sehr unterschiedlichen Systemen unterwegs sind, oder? Gibt es da irgendwie schon Standardisierungsbemühungen, die Fruchten?
Es gibt ein Gremium zur Standardisierung, das UIC, das europaweit gegründet wurde, um Standards festzulegen.
Was heißt das, UIC?
Ach, das ist Französisch. Keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall ist das... Jedenfalls hat sich aus Forschungs-Synergie heraus, nenne ich es mal, ziemlich schnell die Normalspur. Das ist die Spur, die wir auch in Deutschland haben, das ist 1.435 mm Abstand zwischen den beiden Gleisen. Als Standard festgelegt, hat sich einfach so entwickelt. Die kamen aus England, glaube ich, im Oberbürgermeer geschwappt. Das ist im Westen Europas absolut normal, während in Russland eine andere Spur weitergefahren wird, die Breitspur. Das sind 2.100, das geht, glaube ich, auf die über zwei Meter bei der Breitspur.
Das ist richtig breit.
Das ist richtig breit und das ist auch der große Vorteil, weil man halt ziemlich große Massen drüber bewegen kann. Der Zug selbst läuft ruhiger auf diesem Breitspursystem. Also für große Güterzüge auf jeden Fall das bessere System.
Aber wird so nur in Russland verwendet?
Ja, und in den anderen ehemaligen Großstaaten. Das an der polnischen Grenze, glaube ich, wechselt das erst.
Also an der polnischen Grenze zu Russland.
Genau, also Gasprobe ist da zum Beispiel einer, der gerne diese Strecke länger haben möchte, weil sie können dann auch ihre großen Güterzüge mit Flüssiggas bis nach Europa reinfahren. Und momentan müssen die heuer umgeladen werden, auf andere Spurbereiten und ganz andere Lokomotiven. Und das dauert natürlich Zeit. Ja, da gibt es schon zufällig eine ganz gute Standardisierung. Es gibt da immer noch irgendwelche kleinen Nebenbahnen, die Schmalspur sind, und hier und dort gibt es mit Ausnahmen. Aber das ist schon so generell auf den sogenannten Vollbahnen, also vollwertigen Eisenbahnen. Ist das so üblich, die Normalspur? Dann gibt es die großen Unterschiede, die kommen dann erst mal im Lichtraumprofil. Also kann man sich vorstellen, den Schnitt des Fahrzeuges, das nach oben oder nach unten zur Seite oder überstehen kann.
Die Silhouette. Genau.
Wo dann, wie weit in die Fahrspur dann Signale reinstehen dürfen. Und solche Sachen. Also wie groß auch die Tunnel mindestens sein müssen. Also es darf halt einfach während einer Fahrt des Zuges nichts von außen ins Lichtraumprofil reinragen. Das ist so dieser Bereich um den Zug rum, der einfach frei sein muss. Und der ist auch zum Teil relativ groß, da das, glaube ich, auch die Neigertechnik-Züge auch mit reinfallen und die haben natürlich auch noch mal ein bisschen Spielraum. Deswegen wird man sehen, wenn man einen Neigertechnik-Zug sieht, dass er nicht so weit nach oben geht, weil er auch sich zur Seite neigt und dann seitlich überstehen würde. Das ist verständlich. In Skandinavien zum Beispiel fährt man breitere Wagen. Auf der gleichen Spur.
Weil?
Das hat sich auch historisch wieder so entwickelt.
Ist einfach so.
Ist einfach so. Das ist häufig so in der Bahn. Das andere, der größte Unterschied und der wesentlichste Unterschied ist, ansonsten kann man sich immer für den kleinsten gemeinsamen Länder einigen, ist natürlich das Stromnetz. Es gibt verschiedene Spannungen. Manche fahren sogar noch mit Gleichstrom. Also gerade ältere Zugnetze verwenden doch Gleichstrom, aber eigentlich... Also zum Beispiel, ein gutes Beispiel ist jetzt Großbritannien. Da ist ein Drittel des Gesamtnetzes nur elektrifiziert. Das hat politische Gründe, dass es sehr früh privatisiert wurde und dann niemand mehr in die Netzinfrastruktur investiert hat. Und da ist im Süden, glaube ich südlich von der Themse, ist Gleichstrom noch. Mit einer Seitenschiene auf, glaube ich, 750 Volt wird Gleichstrom gefahren, was Nachteile hat, dass man eben nicht so hohe Spannungen drauf fahren kann.
Eine Seitenschiene für die Stromversorgung?
Genau, wie bei der Berliner S-Bahn. Das ist genau das gleiche System eigentlich. Oder bei der Hamburger. Die Spannungen sind unterschiedlich, aber das ist das gleiche System. Die Berliner S-Bahn ist auch eigentlich, nach meinem Wissen, die erste im Regelbetrieb befindliche elektrifizierte Bahn in Deutschland, dass eben auch so entstanden ist. Also im Stadtnetz macht Gleichstrom auch Sinn, weil man es nicht so weit übertragen muss, weil man leichtere Fahrzeuge hat. Die Transfumatoren fallen weg, die Motoren müssen nicht so leistungsfähig sein. Die nicht so hohe Spannung macht kein Problem. Aber es gibt halt ganze Staaten.
Mit welcher Spannung wird da gearbeitet?
Ich glaube, das Berliner Netz hat, glaube ich, 660 Volt. 660, ja.
Okay, also macht schon Aua, wenn man das mal abkriegt.
Da ist auch richtig Strom drauf. Es gibt auch richtig viel Technologie, dass man halt einfach nicht reingreifen kann. Ich kenne zum Beispiel in Frankreich gibt es einige Straßenbahnen, die wirklich einfach eine Stromschiene haben, die im Boden liegt und die dann von Bewegungsprofilen her einfach nur den Strom da zur Verfügung stellt, wo dann der Zug aktuell ist.
Ach echt?
Da versucht man schon, möglichst sofort zu gehen. Das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass da jemand wirklich...
Aber der Strom ist sozusagen in der Schiene, wo die Bahn drauf fährt?
Ach so, nein. Das sind immer einzelne Blöcke, also Stromschiene. Dann gibt es ein paar Meter keinen Strom. Dadurch kann man diese einzelne Stromschiene, wo der Zug sich gerade drauf befindet, elektrifizieren. Dann fährt er weiter und die nächste Stromschiene aktiviert.
Also mehr als ein Abnehmer. Während der einen noch verbunden ist, steigt er auf den nächsten um.
Der Zug ist auf beiden Schienen nötig. Es gibt auch interessante Stellen, wo es Bahnübergänge gibt in solchen Bodenschienenbereichen, wo dann einfach ein Fahrzeug den Kontakt verliert, weil es nicht über den Bahnübergang aus Sicherheitsgründen kein Strom geführt wird. Und das hintere Fahrzeug aber noch Strom hat. Das ist sehr abenteuerlich.
Aber bei der Berliner S-Bahn ist das dann so durchgehend. Da hat man einfach überall Strom. Da sollte man auch nicht drauf marschieren, nicht anfassen.
Der greift von unten noch mal so rein in die Stromfasern. Also bei der Berliner S-Bahn ist es an der Seite. Man sieht das an der Seite, so eine Konstruktion, von so einer extra Trägerschiene, wo das drin hängt. Und das ist die der Bahnsteig abgewandte Seite.
Man kann da nicht mal so dran fassen, man müsste schon so richtig rein. Und schon aufs Gleis und dann handkrumm und so weiter.
Es gibt halt ganze Staatennetze, die mit Gleichstrom laufen, eben die Niederlande als Beispiel. Ich glaube, auch afrikanische Bahnen sind zum Teil. Niederlande ist ein prominentes Beispiel, weil das eben Nachbarstaat ist und auch ECS dort reinfahren, die dann eben extra Strom abnehmen haben für dieses Netz.
Also es gibt da keine Strecke, die so ist wie in Deutschland, sondern da muss sozusagen der Zug in der Lage sein, mit dem anderen Stromnetz klarzukommen.
Ein gutes anderes Beispiel ist auch hier Karlsruhe, wenn ich kurz einwerfen darf. Also hier in Karlsruhe haben wir auch in der Straßenbahn ein Gleichspannungsnetzwerk, Stromnetz. Und die Züge fahren aber trotzdem von 1400 Millimeter auch hier an Spurweite. Und können dann aber auch aufs Deutsche Bahnnetz drauffahren. Und es gibt dann an bestimmten Stellen, wo dann die S-Bahn hier in Karlsruhe bestimmte Läufe haben, wo sie runterfahren und dann wechseln sie unser Stromnetz und fahren dann auf den Wechselspannungsnetz der Deutschen Bahn einfach weiter. Dafür ist auch Karlsruhe ein bisschen einzigartig. Also die Geschichte dahinter kann ich noch kurz erläutern. Also Karlsruhe hat traditionell so ein Tram-Straßenbahnsystem mit Gleichstrom, das sie so entwickelt hat. Und rundherum gab es sehr viele kleine Nebenbahnen. Das war die Badische Staatsbahn. Und diese Nebenbahnen waren vom Aussterben bedroht, wurden auch teilweise zurückgebaut. Und die Stadt Karlsruhe hat sich dann überlegt, dass sie die Bahn doch versucht zu erhalten, also in Eigenregie. Mit den Karlsruhe Verkehrsbetrieben, Verkehrsbetriebe Karlsruhe, VBK. Und die Überlegung war halt, wie man das am besten anbindet. Weil diese Regionalbahnen, die dort früher gefahren sind, wenig ausgelastet waren, weil sie eben am Bahnhof fielten. Der Bahnhof ist eben relativ weit im Süden. Also die Anbindung an die Innenstadt ist suboptimal. Dann haben sie sich überlegt, nach diesem Karlsruher Modell, so wurde es dann genannt, sind dann andere Städte adaptiert, haben sie dann spezielle Straßenbahnfahrzeuge bestellt, die in der Lage sind, eben auch auf dem Deutsche Bahnnetz zu fahren und auch den Sicherheitsbestimmungen der Deutschen Bahn zu entsprechen. Also nicht der Deutschen Bahn, sondern heutzutage der Eisebahnbetriebsordnung. Wir haben eine extra Betriebsordnung für das Vollbahnnetz im Vergleich zum Straßenbahnnetz. Da darf nicht auf Sicht gefahren werden, da muss mit dem ganzen Signalisierungssystem gefahren werden. Dazu werden wir später noch was sagen. Und so hat sich das halt entwickelt. Und so hat sich erst wieder so einen Aufschwung auf diesen Nebenbahn in Karlsruhe entwickelt. Zum Beispiel Bretten, eine Stadt auf Stuttgart damals. War früher eine Stadt auf Eberstrecke, nicht ganz Eberstrecke, aber nach Stuttgart. War früher sehr stark an Stuttgart angebunden, weil es dort auch eine wichtige Hauptstrecke vorbeilief. Das hat sich mittlerweile erledigt. Durch diese direkte Anbindung, dass man von mehreren Halten innerhalb Bretten direkt zum Karlsruher Marktplatz fahren kann, ist das sehr stark nach Karlsruhe orientiert. So kann das politisch sehr interessant sein. Das ist auch technisch sehr interessant, weil dieses Stromnetz gewechselt wird. Das ist der kleine Ausflug dahin. In Deutschland haben sie sich ein eigenes Netz ausgedacht. Mit 15 kV fahren wir auf einem 16,77-Hertz-Netz. Das ist ungefähr ein Drittel unseres Industriestroms. Das hatte Folgengründe, dass damals in der Nachkriegszeit die Motoren noch nicht so gut zu bauen waren, dass das 50-Hertz-Netz gefahren werden kann. Transformatoren waren damals auch noch teurer. Deswegen haben wir uns für das andere entschieden. Es ist aber dann mit der Drittelabstufung geblieben, um die Transformation vom Industriestromnetz in das Bahnnetz günstiger zu gestalten.
Was meinst du mit Drittelabstufung?
Dass die Frequenz nur ein Drittel ist.
Also 16,7 ist ein Drittel davon.
Nicht ganz genau, aber mittlerweile haben sie es geändert. Früher war es genau ein Drittel. Das war das deutsche Modell. Das hat Österreich und die skandinavischen Länder. Also nicht alle, sondern nur Norwegen und Schweden. Andere Staaten, die ein bisschen später auf diesen Zug aufgesprungen sind, die haben...
Ich glaube, wir werden noch mehr solche Dinge haben.
Die haben 25 Kilovolt auf 50 Hertz. Also die haben direkt das Industriestromnetz. Man kann es sich nicht einfach dem Netz entnehmen, weil die Lasten sehr groß sind und so weiter. Aber theoretisch ist es möglich. Also es ist gar ein geringerer technischer Aufwand auf Seiten der Netzinfrastruktur.
Industriestrom, also das ist sozusagen der Industriestandard.
Aus der Steckdose das.
25 Kilovolt? 15.
25 fahren die von anderen Ländern. Also Frankreich.
Oder 25.000 Volt. Das ist ja nicht das, was aus der Steckdose kommt.
Nein, natürlich nicht. Aber die Frequenz ist halt einfach das, was aus dem...
50 Hertz. Also mehr Leistung, aber halt dieselbe Wechselfrequenz. Und bei der Bahn in Deutschland, Österreich, ist es halt sozusagen noch mal durch drei geteilt. Weil früher war das mal ein Problem. Heute wäre es kein Problem mehr. Aber es wäre ein echtes Problem, das jetzt noch zu ändern.
Genau, es ist ein großes Problem, das zu ändern. Also die Franzosen haben dieses modernere Modell. Und östlich war Deutschland auch wieder. Außer in Polen, glaube ich. Weil dort... Polen hat, glaube ich, auch gleich Strom. Weil dort es halt modern neu aufgebaut wurde. Weil da bis in die neuere Zeit nur Diesel-KV geherrscht hat. Und es hat halt die freie Wahl gehabt. Und dort ist dann auch dieses französische Modell. Das ist das Modernere.
Wo ist das jetzt entstanden?
Es sind mehrere Länder draufgekommen.
Ich weiß nicht, wer ist jetzt auf das französische Modell?
Die östlicheren Staaten, die...
Also welche?
Tschechien, solche Staaten. Also die, die in der einmaligen Sowjetunion waren und jetzt in Europa sind.
Bietet das Vorteile?
Es ist einfacher einzuspeisen vom normalen...
Weil man sozusagen den Strom nicht nochmal umwandeln muss.
Man hat eine höhere Spannung und kann leistungsfähige Patoren bauen. Es war früher auch alles lockseitig ein Problem. Das ist heute einfacher.
Das heißt, Deutschland ist eigentlich so eine Legacy-Insel.
Ja, aber es ist jetzt nichts dramatisches. Das kann man in Lokomotiven auch abfedern. Das ist kein Problem, jetzt Züge zu bauen, die in beiden Netzen klarkommen. Der TGW macht das, der IC macht das ja auch. Es ist halt einfach nur damit verständlich, warum jetzt irgendeine Regionalbahn nicht einfach über die Grenze fahren kann und ins französischen Netz weiterfahren kann. Das ist eben eine dieser Hürden.
Aber das ist schon insofern auffällig, als dass es schon eine signifikante Investition in ein bestimmtes Zugmodell wäre, wenn man das jetzt unbedingt haben wollen würde. Es ist nicht so, dass man sagt, naja, mach mal hier die Frequenz auch noch mit rein. Das passt schon, das ist schon so ein bisschen viel.
Ja klar, man hat dann hunderte von diesen Loktypen, wo das gemacht werden muss. Nachrüsten geht auch nicht in den meisten Fällen. Sonst betrifft dann die neue Modelle.
Produziert die Bahn ihren Strom selber?
Das gibt eine DB Energie, die damals von der Deutschen Bahn ausgegriffen wurde. Die kauft das auch wieder auf den Markt. Hat aber, glaube ich, sogar ein Kraftwerk oder so. Sie haben Kraftwerke und die halten sich sogar auch. Sie haben Pump-Speicher sehen, wo sie billigen Strom nachts hochpumpen.
Also in Pumpen, Wasserpumpen speichern.
Und dann zu Stoßzeiten wieder ablaufen lassen.
Ich meine, der Energiebedarf des Gesamtnetzes ist ja nicht gering, oder?
Ja, du hattest mal geschaut, wie viel ein ICE3, wie viel Watt der... 9,8 Megawatt, was der aus dem Netz zieht. Das ist dann schon...
9,8 Megawatt.
Das ist schon der Betriebsbedarf. Maximal. Also das ist schon was.
Maximal, das heißt, wenn er volle Power den Berg hochfährt, oder so? Okay, aber jetzt noch mal im vollen Zug. Aber das ist jetzt auch nicht der Mittelwert, sozusagen.
Nein, das ist schon wirklich das Maximum.
Und so normalerweise?
Gute Frage. Ist halt echt schwer eigentlich einzuschätzen, weil man kann... ICEs können inzwischen sehr ökonomisch fahren. Die Bremsen können Strom zurückspeisen ins Stromnetz. Was zum Beispiel Hannover, glaube ich, die Strecke runter häufig passiert, dass die ICE dann schon ein Teil des Stromes wieder produzieren, was der andere ICE braucht, um hochzukommen. Und je nachdem, wie man den Zug fährt, kann man da bestimmt, denke ich, auf die Hefte runtergehen. Ich weiß, dass das Spekulation ist, glaube ich, von meiner Sicht.
Die Strecke runter, weiß ich, kann ich auch absolut nichts sagen. Aus der süddeutschen Sicht, also sozusagen aus den Mittelgebirgen, ins flache Land runterfährt, da wird Strom erzeugt.
Genau, das ist im Gleichstromnetz auch eine schwierige Sache. Ja, also es gibt dann die andere Unterschiede jetzt europaweit, um das noch abzuschließen, sind die Sicherungssysteme. Da haben viele Länder, vor allem die größeren Länder, sich ihre eigenen ausgedacht. Und die kleinere Länder haben da meist von irgendeinem größeren Land ihrer Wahl das dann abgekupfert. Und da gibt es eben erst mal eine Signalisierung alleine. Es gibt eigentlich relativ vieles. Damals die Formsignale, die ich sie am Anfang gab, das sind diese Kellen, die dann immer so hoch und runter gingen.
Was vom Damals reden wir denn jetzt? Also ich meine, welchen Zustand geben wir denn aus? Ganz am Anfang gab es irgendwie mal so einen Zug, der da irgendwo langfuhr. Und du musstest dich damit nicht groß abstimmen. Und wenn da mal eine Kuh dazwischen war, dann war das nicht ganz gut.
Genau, das fängt an, dass es erst mal nur ein Zug auf der ganzen Strecke war. Und dann waren plötzlich mehrere Züge auf der Strecke. Und dann hat man so Sicherungsposten gehabt, wo einfach ein Mensch drin war, der gesagt hat, nee, du darfst jetzt nicht auf die Strecke, weil da ist schon einer. Da ist schon einer durchgefahren. Und ich habe noch kein Telegramm gekriegt, dass es irgendwie angekommen ist.
Wo kam das Telegramm her?
Das wurde Drahtübertragung, genau. Und das kam halt dann von nächsten Posten, die dann gesagt haben, jetzt ist der Zug aus meinem Bereich wieder rausgefahren. Jetzt kannst du den Bereich wieder freigeben, sodass du wieder nicht fahren kannst. Davor, wo auch noch viele Umfälle entstanden sind, war, dass man einfach in Zeitabständen die Züge auf die Strecke geschickt hat. Du hast gesagt, okay, da ist jetzt eine halbe Stunde auf der Strecke. Wenn der Probleme hat, dann reicht das trotzdem noch. Dann wurde der nächste draufgelassen und dann sind Unfälle passiert. Deswegen hat man dann angefangen mit Blöcken. Diese Blöcke in moderner Form hat man heute immer noch.
Blöcke im Sinne von geografischer Unterteilung?
Geografischer Unterteilung der Strecke. In einem Block darf immer nur ein Zug sein. Nur aus der Überwachung automatisiert erfolgt.
Wie groß muss man sich das vorstellen, so ein Block?
Das ist eine Stellschraube, wo Eisenbahner schauen können, wie schnell sie die Strecke hinbekommen. Was sie für Durchsätze auf der Strecke brauchen. Wenn man einen Nebenbahn hat, kann ein Block sehr lang sein. Zwischen zwei Bahnhöfen kann es 20-30 km sein, aber es kann auch nur 2 km sein.
Aber so in dem Bereich bewegt sich das ungefähr? Nicht so 100 m strecken oder so?
Der Zug muss ja noch genug Raum haben, um stehen bleiben zu können an einem roten Signal.
Das ist sozusagen die Definition, dass man genug Platz und Zeit hat, um gehen zu bleiben. Das hängt auch von der durchschnittlich gefahrenen Geschwindigkeit ab.
Ganz genau, das ist ein ganz interessantes Thema. Es ist nämlich so, dass es in Deutschland 1 km vor Signal Abstand gibt. Das heißt, das Signal, das dem Triebfahrzeugführer sagt, das nächste Signal ist rot, hat 1 km Abstand. In diesem Bereich muss der Zug zum Stehen kommen können. Das schränkt uns in gewisser Weise ein. Da gehören Züge, wie in anderen Ländern nicht denkbar, die sich kilometerlang sind. Erst mal würden die gar nicht in einen Block passen. Das ist das eine Problem. Solche Züge brauchen sehr lange, um stehen zu bleiben. Alleine, bis sich der Bremsbefehl auf den Zug ausgebreitet hat. Das ist nicht so ohne Weiteres möglich. Deswegen gibt es diesen 1 km Abstand. Dann gibt es auch eine gewisse Vorschrift. Bei jedem Zug, bevor der in Betrieb genommen wird, bevor der gefahren wird, wird eine Bremsprobe gemacht, um sicherzustellen, dass dieses Bremsvermögen gegeben ist. Dass der Zug in der Lage ist, in dem Bereich zum Stehen zu bleiben. Der Zug der Triebwagenführer musste damals auch die Bremsunterzettel seines Zuges ausrechnen. Er musste dann nachvollziehen, dass er immer in diesem Bereich stehenbleiben kann. Wenn nicht, musste er seine Maximalgeschwindigkeit anpassen. Genau. Das war Handarbeit damals auch alles. Das ist heute auch noch so. Häufig werden es aber von Computern inzwischen gemacht.
Ich hatte mal einen Verwandten, der war Schrankenwärter. Lang ist es her. Das war so... Das muss so Ende der 70er-Jahre gewesen sein. So die Zeit. Und da lief neben der Schiene so drähtelang. So Signalisierungsdrähte. Wo er sozusagen immer von seinem... Weiß gar nicht, von wem, von irgendjemandem, der vor ihm in der Strecke ist, signalisiert bekommen hat, dass da jetzt irgendwie ein Zug kommt. Ist das heute auch noch... Gibt es diese Technologie noch?
Also, dass Datenübertragung da stattfindet, ist natürlich überdreht, das ist klar. Aber es ist so, dass bei Bahnübergängen jetzt... Genau, da ist immer ein sogenanntes Schutzsignal davor.
Also, die Drähte waren jetzt keine Drähte, über die elektronische Kommunikation getrieben wurde, sondern mechanische Schiebeteile.
Ja, genau, das war ein mechanisches Stellwerk. Die gibt es heute auch noch, aber auf Nebenstrecken. Und sie werden immer weiter abgebaut. Das sind die, wo man dann häufig diese Signale mit den...
Das war eigentlich ganz praktisch, weil man konnte schon daran merken, dass ein Zug kommt, dass die angefangen haben zu zittern. Der Zug hat dann schon über zwei Kilometer angekündigt, bevor man überhaupt was gesehen hat.
Es ist harte Arbeit und man brauchte mehr Arbeitskräfte dafür. Man sollte versuchen, so etwas zu zentralisieren und elektronisch durchzuführen, was dann einfacher ist. Züge kann man immer noch häufig erkennen anhand der Signalstellung, die man auch so betrachten kann, wenn einer kommt. Genau, aber um noch mal auf Bahnübergänge zurückzukommen, das läuft so, dass der Bahnübergang heutzutage, wenn er geschlossen ist, ich glaube, ein Stromkreis wahrscheinlich geschlossen wird oder ein Kontakt aktiviert wird oder sonst was, der signalisiert, ja, der Bahnübergang ist geschlossen. Erst dann wird ein sogenanntes Schutzsignal auf grün geschaltet davor. Das heißt, es ist nicht möglich, dass der Zug durchfährt, während die Schranken noch oben sind. Das ist eigentlich bei überall in der Bahntechnik so. Bei Weichen ist es auch so, dass da nochmal ein Kontakt besteht, das auch wirklich mechanisch überprüft werden kann. Die Weiche ist in der entsprechenden Stellung eingerastet und ist damit das Signal auch für den Zug gegeben, dass er überhaupt weiterfahren darf oder diese Weiche auch fahren darf. Und aus dem Stellwerk heraus ist dieses Signal gar nicht ansprechbar. Das heißt, das Stellwerk spricht nur den Bahnübergang oder die Weiche an. Und das Signal wird dann lokal.
Das ist der Weiche selber und von dem Bahnübergang selber gegeben. So dass man nicht sagen kann, naja, ich hab der Schranke gesagt, mach dich mal zu und dann macht sie sich gar nicht zu und er fährt trotzdem weiter. Stellwerk, wie viele gibt es davon? Wofür braucht man? Was kann ein Stellwerk so überblicken?
Also wie viele es gibt, weiß ich nicht. Es werden weniger. Es werden immer weniger, weil es halt kostengünstiger ist, das zu zentralisieren. Ein Beispiel ist ein größeres, das bis nach Freiburg runter... Alle Weichen kontrolliert? Alle Weichen im elektronischen Bereich kontrolliert. Vielleicht gibt es Nebenbahnen, wo es nicht der Fall ist, aber...
Also so ein Stellwerk kann mehrere Hundert Kilometer in jede Richtung überblicken. Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass man hier eins hat und dann um die Ecke ist das schon wieder das nächste.
Lokal gibt es dann Notfallposten, falls irgendwas in der Kommunikation fehlt, kann da ein Mensch hinfahren. Lokal hat er noch einen kleinen Kommandoposten, wo man von das noch steuern könnte. Das sind garagen, die in der Landschaft sind. Das ist dann ein Notfallarm. Ansonsten wird das alles dann zentral gesteuert.
Ja, es ist ja wirklich eine sehr komplexe Angelegenheit. Man macht sich ja immer gar nicht so richtig klar, was eigentlich so alles dazu gehört. Vielleicht können wir ja einfach mal reisen. Kann man nicht mal irgendwo hinfahren? Ich meine, wenn man jetzt so einen Zug hat, der fährt von Hamburg nach Karlsruhe. Vielleicht keine gängige Strecke, aber kann man das auch machen. Ist die so mehr oder weniger direkt verbunden? Von wo auch immer er losfährt. Aber jetzt muss ja erst mal so ein Zug zusammengestellt werden. Er muss irgendwie bereitgestellt werden. Vielleicht gehen wir jetzt auch mal erst mal nicht vom ICE aus, weil ich glaube, das ist noch mal eine ganz eigene Geschichte. Aber so diese klassischen Züge, die halt einfach aus Wagen und Lokomotiven bestehen.
Also das Ganze beginnt schon Jahre davor, wo die Planung für den Fahrplan beginnt. Da wird vorher schon festgelegt, welche Züge wann wo fahren. Also inklusive Wagen-Nummer und Reihung der Wagen. Welches Fahrzeug dort drin stecken wird, planmäßig? An welchem Gleis es ankommen wird?
Jahre vorher.
Es gibt vorher eine Fahrplanverhandlung, wo dann die Trassen gebucht werden. Und das ist ein sehr komplexes... Das ist wirklich sehr schwierig. Vor allem, weil auch der Starter mit reinreden kann, weil natürlich dann Leute auf Trassen bieten können. Die Netzregulierung. Genau, da läuft so viel zusammen. Und das ist halt schon ein Prozess, der dauert Jahre, bis man halt so einen Fahrplan dann ausrollen kann. Wie die Deutsche Bahn.
Das heißt, die Bahn wäre gar nicht in der Lage, so mal eben mitten im Jahr zu beschließen, wir brauchen da jetzt nochmal eine neue Verbindung.
Keine Chance. Es gibt halt Ausnahmen, dass irgendwelche Züge ausfallen und dass deswegen was anders gemacht wird oder dass irgendeine Katastrophe ist oder sonst was. Aber das darf nicht regulär so passieren. Man kann nicht einfach... Die Bahn kann nicht einfach sagen, oh, hier könnte jetzt ein größeres Potenzial sein, jetzt setzen wir hier einen weiteren Zug rein. Das wird alles auch staatlich reguliert. Das ist schon nicht so einfach. Man glaubt gar nicht, dass die Regulierung so groß ist. Aber die Regulierung innerhalb des Verkehrswesens ist sehr groß. Es ist ganz genau festgelegt, wie viele Verbindungen zwischen zwei Städten bestehen dürfen und wo die rüberlaufen müssen usw. Man darf nicht einfach ein Busunternehmen aufmachen zwischen Stadt A und Stadt B. Bus-Passagiere fahren. Das ist nicht so einfach. Aber das erste ist die Planung der Trasse. Das wird jahrem vorausgemacht. Dann müssen natürlich Fahrzeuge dafür festgelegt werden. Die eigentliche Zusammenstellung der Fahrzeuge erfolgt... Das ist ein Drangierbetrieb im Bahnhof, der aus den Lagerhallen die Züge zusammenstellt. Und wird entsprechend auch bereitgestellt. Das ist kein großes Unterfangen. Die Waggons stehen meistens im Freien. Aber man hat einen Lager von solchen Zügen. Die werden von Teilen dieser Züge zusammengestellt.
Hamburg ist ein gutes Beispiel. Altona ist eigentlich ein typischer Bahnhof.
Es gibt dann bestimmte Rangier-Fahrpläne, wonach rangiert werden muss. Selbst in diesen Bahnhöfen noch mal selber drin. Die richten sich dann auch nicht nach den Fortschriften des normalen Bahnverkehrs. Also innerhalb eines Bahnhofs darf man anders fahren als außerhalb eines Bahnhofs. Und das ist wahrscheinlich schon wieder fast eine ganze Welt für sich selber. Das sind auch keine Züge. Das gilt nicht als Zug, weil es nicht auf die freie Strecke rausfährt. Das ist einfach nur Rangierbetrieb. Die müssen sich auch nicht an Signale halten. Die haben eigene Regelungen, die haben eigene Signale.
So ein bisschen wie Flughafen.
Genau.
Das ist gewuselig.
Da dürfen dann die 40 km abfahren. Und da kann man meistens noch mal schnell die Bremse reinhauen. Da wird versucht, die Züge so zusammenzustellen, wie es ursprünglich gedacht war. Man hört trotzdem sehr häufig, dass die Reihenfolge der Züge verdreht ist. Dann gibt es halt Ausnahmesituationen, dann ist hier die Klimaanlage kaputt und dann wird hoffentlich der Wagen ausgetauscht. Oder andere Probleme, dass der Wagen noch gar nicht angekommen ist, der eigentlich dafür gedacht ist.
Aber wer kommentiert denn diese Phase? Also unter wessen Obhut ist so dieser... Es gibt da einen Bestellungsprozess.
Bestimmte Betriebszentralen, die sich dann entweder in den Bahnhöfen, also große Bahnhöfe machen, haben meistens selber noch eine Betriebszentrale, die dann sowas regelt. Das sind dann meistens in den Bahnhöfen irgendwelche Räume, wo Leute vor den Rechnern sitzen und dann diese Rangierfahrten planen. Und dann auch die entsprechenden Weichen stellen, dann den Fahrweg freigeben, sodass der Zug überhaupt rollen kann. Das wird in den Bahnhöfen meistens selber gemacht. Da gibt es keine sehr große zentrale...
Mit so einem Stellwerk hat das nichts zu tun?
Es ist die Technik von einem Stellwerk, die aber durchaus anders verwendet wird in dem Fall. Also die Signale können wirklich selber direkt geschaltet werden. Und man fährt eigentlich relativ viel auf Befehl. Das heißt, man kann, wenn man auch im Bahnhofsverkehr ist, ein rotes Signal überfahren, wenn man in einer Rangierfahrt ist. Die haben Kandgültigkeit, diese klassischen Signale. Also es ist einfach...
Passiert da viel?
An Unfällen. Also wenn dann passiert, nichts Schlimmes. Es passieren viele kleinere Sachen, aber durch die geringen Geschwindigkeiten, fahren auf Sicht sehr langsam, passiert eigentlich nichts. Und das ist nochmal ganz klar, also nur noch darauf, das klarzustellen, dass es absolut getrennt vom regulären Betrieb. Also es kann auch nicht sein, dass ein Zug, der jetzt so eine Vollbahn, die im Regelbetrieb ist und halt Passagiere hat, kann nicht interagieren mit diesem Rangierbetrieb. Das sind komplett getrennte Gleisen, die dürfen in dem Moment halt einfach nicht zusammenlaufen. Das ist halt durch verschiedene Sicherheitssysteme auch dann garantiert, dass das nicht passieren kann. Es gibt da sowas wie sogenannte Schutzweichen. Es läuft folgendermaßen ab, dass wenn ein Zug die Möglichkeit hätte, auf einen Gleis zu fahren, was im Betrieb ist und wo richtig Personenzug oder sonst was drauf fährt, und er die Möglichkeit hätte einfach reinzufahren, auch wenn es noch so langsam ist, einfach reinzurutschen, nur weil er rangieren ist, einfach reinzufahren, dann wird normalerweise noch eine zweite Weiche angebaut, die immer so umgestellt ist auf einen Stumpfgleis, dass der Zug nicht auf die Hauptstrecke fährt, sondern immer auf das Stumpfgleis drauf. Gab es einen Fall in Augsburg, wo ein Güterzug tatsächlich im Fluss geschickt wurde, weil er sonst in den ICE-Verkehr eingegriffen hätte. Das ist halt billiger in dem Fall. Er ist quasi aus Versehen, hat sich vertan, ist losgefahren. Aber weil die Schutzweiche gestellt war, ist er in den See gefahren. Und nicht in die ICE-Strecke.
Und das Gleis führt direkt in den See?
Das war in Freiburg am Ende. Ein Signal auch überfahren, wie wir später noch zukommen werden. Und danach auch entsprechend Geschwindigkeit beschleunigen.
Das heißt, da fährt jetzt irgendjemand mit seiner Rangier-Lok so lange hin und her und zupft sich die Wagen von den Gleisen, baut den Zug zusammen und irgendjemand in der Betriebszentrale überwacht das mehr oder weniger. Und dann ist dann der Zug irgendwann fertig.
Genau, die Wagen werden aneinander gekoppelt, dann werden die Elektrosysteme miteinander verbunden.
Was muss denn da immer verkoppelt werden? Kommt da einfach so ein dicker Schlauch und irgendwie Haken?
Es kommt erst einmal diese Haken, diese Kupplung. Da wird meist auch noch eine Schraube dran oder sonst was. Es gibt verschiedene Kupplungsformen. Es gibt auch mittlerweile automatische Scharfenberg-Kupplung. Magnetische. Es gibt da verschiedene Systeme. Das ist auch wieder so eine Ländersache. Das ist auch wieder so ein Integrationsproblem.
Man kann nicht mal eben jeden Wagen an den anderen dranhängen.
Es ist auch nicht so, dass wirklich jetzt wirklich alle Züge neu gekoppelt werden. Das ist bei Güterverkehr vielleicht so. Aber im Personenverkehr sind häufig die Zug-Reihungen schon stabil.
Die bleiben einfach zusammen.
Es gibt auch wieder Standards und so. Aber das ist die eine Sache. Dann wird das Elektrosystem aneinander gekoppelt, dass eben die Klimaanlage und Licht und Ähnliches in allen Zugteilen funktioniert. Und das Wichtige ist die Pressluftleitung für die Bremse. Die Hauptluftleitung, genau. Das Bremsen in Zügen ist nämlich eine ganz interessante Sache, weil der Standardzustand einer Zugbremse ist Bremsen. Und man muss aktiv nicht bremsen.
Also muss gegenhalten.
Man drückt quasi mit Luftdruck die Bremsen hoch. Oder wenn man sich eine alte Bremse vorstellt, die Bremsklötze vom Rad weg. So war das früher. Und sobald diese Leitung reißt, wird automatisch überall gebremst, weil der Luftdruck eben abfällt. Mittlerweile sind es natürlich keine Klotzbremsen mehr, außer bei alten Güterwagen. Aber Scheibenbremsen, da gibt es noch verschiedene Formen. Es gibt eben die vorhin schon angesprochenen dynamischen Bremsen, die eben Strom auch zurückspeisen können mit Wirbel-Strombremsen. Es gibt noch Magnetschienenbremsen, die sich einfach mit der Schiene festkrallen und dann einfach mit Hilfe der Schiene und nicht des Rades bremsen. Die man in ICS eingebaut ist, um bei hohen Geschwindigkeiten schnell bremsen zu können, die aber eben auch die Schiene erwärmen. Also es ist dann auch keine Komfortbremsung mehr? Es ist keine Standardbremsung, es ist wirklich nur für so schnell Bremsungen. Es gilt im Zugverkehr so diese Regel, dass man nicht schneller als 1 m pro Sekundenquadrat beschleunigen oder bremsen darf, um den Fahrgästen bestimmten Komfort zu geben. Und wenn man so was dann macht, dann bremsen wir schon ziemlich.
Man könnte auch schneller zum Stehen kommen.
Ja klar, das geht schon sehr schnell. Das will man nicht unbedingt.
Dann ist ja ein oder andere Mageninhalt gegebenenfalls gefährdet.
Ja, ganz genau. Ja und genau, wenn der Druck abfällt, wird eben gebremst. Der Triebfahrzeugführer hat das sogenannte Führerbremsventil. Das haben wir immer sehr schöne Namen im Deutschen.
Führerbremsventil.
Das ist entsprechend abgekürzt. Der kann den Luftdruck eben senken. Dann macht der Ventil auf und dann wird gebremst. Und weil das eben Luftdruck ist und das sich begrenzt ausbreitet im Zug, gibt es dann auch gewisse Spannungen und Druck auf die verschiedenen Kupplungen. Das ist schon eine kompliziertere Sache. Es ist auf einmal das Problem, dass dann die ersten Wagons anfangen zu bremsen, während die hinteren noch frei rollen und nach vorne drücken. Bei Güterzügen kann man dann entsprechend langsam nur bremsen. Deswegen auch wieder dieses Problem mit dem 1 km Vor-Signal-Abstand. Also Bremssegel sind sehr lang. Ich wurde schon kurz angesprochen, dass es eine Zeit dauert, dass sich das im ganzen Zug rumgesprochen hat, dass jetzt gebremst wird. Das habe ich damit gemeint.
Weil es sich sozusagen auch wirklich nur über diesen Luftdruck ausbreitet. Es gibt jetzt kein elektrisches Signal, womit man den Luftdruck dann dezentral ablassen könnte. Es gibt immer nur eine einzige Stelle, wo man das regelt.
Die dynamischen Bremsen haben natürlich noch mal eigene Steuerung, aber das Hauptbremssystem, wo man einen Zug schon mal schnell bekommt...
Und dieser Druck wird dann von der Lokomotive erzeugt?
Genau, dass die Bremsen weiter... Ja, da ist ein Kompressor drin, kann man sich so vorstellen. Das dauert dann auch immer einen Moment, um das vollzuladen. Das hört man, das bei älteren Straßenbahnen. Die haben das auch, das System. Wenn die stehenbleibt, dann tuckert es eine Weile.
Das ist auch so ein Geräusch, das kennt jeder, vom Zug fahren. Gerade, wenn man mit älteren Zügen unterwegs ist, wird da immer viel gepfffft und so. Wenn abgelassen wird, wird gebremst. Also wenn es pffft macht, bremst gerade jemand. Und dann läuft ja auch der Kompressor wieder ganz ordentlich. Und drückt dann wieder...
Eine andere Sache, die man vielleicht noch am Bahnhof beobachten kann, sind Hebel an den Waggons, in die man verschiedene Stellungen bringen kann.
Da gibt es dann Hebel.
Da gibt es dann z.B. eine bestimmte Einstellung, dass man sich in einem Personenwagenverbund befindet, dass man also dann schneller anfängt zu bremsen. Oder dass die Bremse selber noch mal selbstständig verzögert. Wenn man z.B. auf die Stellung G schaltet, ist man im Güterzugverbund und dann wirkt die Bremse langsamer, um den Luftdruck sich erst ausbreiten zu lassen. Weil die Zugverbände länger sind im Güterzug?
Das ist eher gleichmäßig. Genau. Und warum bei Personen nicht?
Weil die nicht so lang sind. Ganz einfach.
Es ist eher eine Information über die Zuglänge, als über wer da jetzt drin sitzt.
Genau. Mittlerweile geht es auch noch schneller, glaube ich. Es gibt noch eine Erstellung für Schnellbremsung. Ich glaube, Güterzüge werden noch inzwischen in P gefahren.
Ich glaube auch. Es sei denn, sie sind besonders lang.
In Deutschland geht es halt nicht so richtig lang.
Wie lang kann denn so ein Güterzug sein?
In Deutschland 750 Meter.
750 Meter?
Das ist in vielen anderen Ländern halt nichts.
Was gibt es da so?
In Amerika hat man zweieinhalb Kilometer lange Züge. In Australien, was war es? Die zehn Kilometer, ich weiß es nicht, so ewig lange Dinge.
Zehn Kilometer lange Züge?
Ich habe mich jetzt nicht darauf festnageln lassen, aber irgendwas hatte ich mal gehört. Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Auf jeden Fall mehrere Kilometer lang.
Unfassbar.
Wie kriegt man die denn überhaupt? Ist das jetzt ökonomisch sinnvoll? Spart man sich da so viel?
Da kommen drei Diesel-Lokomotiven davor, viel Sand auf die Schiene und dann halt auf den Pass. Weiß ich nicht, ob das energetisch sich lohnt, aber wahrscheinlich deswegen gemacht, weil es sich lohnt.
So wird es auf jeden Fall gemacht. Aber das dauert ja eine Weile, bis die dann auf Touren kommen.
Die sollen auch nicht so schnell wieder abbremsen. Die fahren ja auch nicht wirklich mit sehr kleinen Blöcken, sondern die haben dann auch wirklich erst mal freie Fahrt. Die haben auch einen GPS an Bord, um ihre Position zu bestimmen und keine irgendwelche Positionsangaben. Europalisen wie Deutschland vielleicht. GPS ist ja bei uns gar nicht verbreitet. Also höchstens vielleicht, um Ansagen zu machen, für Haltestellen in Amerika wird das verwendet, um festzustellen, ob der Zug noch intakt ist und kein Waggon abgefallen ist.
Weil sozusagen jeder Waggon...
Weil die haben nicht dieses Druckluftsystem. Man kann kein zweieinhalb Kilometer langes Druckluftsystem aufbauen.
Das ist eher kompliziert.
Deswegen wird dann wirklich per Funk gebremst.
Ja, verstehe.
Und entsprechend weiß man auch nicht unbedingt, ob das hintere Teil noch dran ist. Früher war am Ende so ein Bremswaggon, wo noch ein Mensch drin saß. Genau, und dann gibt es diesen Zugschluss, der dann signalisiert, dass der Zug zu Ende ist. Und wenn dann auch jemand sieht, dass ein Zug ohne Zugschluss fährt, dann muss man dann auch entsprechend Alarm einleiten oder welche Schritte unternehmen.
Ohne Zugschluss? Was heißt das?
Zugschluss ist einfach eine kleine Tafel, die hinten leuchtstark am Ende des Zuges angebracht wird. Das ist so eine reflektierende Sache. Man kann reflektieren, aber einfach das rote Licht am Ende.
Oder die sprichwörtliche rote Laterne.
Wenn man umgebremste Waggons drin hat, am Ende könnte man die verlieren und man wüsste es nicht.
Auch schon wieder so ein geflügeltes Wort aus der Eisenbahnwelt. Zurück zu unserem Zug. Wir haben es geschafft, die Wagen aneinander zu koppeln. Die waren noch nicht gekoppelt. Dazu muss man etwas einklinken, etwas festschrauben. Das hängt davon ab. Es gibt püffige Varianten. Normalerweise muss man die Elektrik miteinander verbinden. Man muss auch die Druckluft miteinander verbinden. Bevor man das nicht macht, würde sich ein Wagen nicht vom Fleck rühren. Wenn ein Wagen irgendwo rumsteht, ist der einfach immer gebremst. Einfach bei Design. Dann muss man noch eine Lok dazuholen. Die macht man davor. Dann ist der Zug fertig.
Dann schreibt man das alles auf sein schönes Formulat. Man rechnet aus, was es wiegt. Man rechnet diese Brems-Netzeln aus. Das ist eine Relation zwischen der Masse und der Zug. Was ist die Masse, die wirklich bremsen kann? Da es auch Waggons geben kann, die keine aktiven Bremsen haben, muss man das in eine Relation setzen. Dann gibt es bestimmte Faktoren, die pro Lokomotive und Waggon reingerechnet werden müssen. Um sicherzustellen, dass die Bremsfähigkeit gegeben ist.
Mit der jeweils verwendeten Lok?
Genau, mit der gesamten Zug. Sobald sich wieder was ändert, muss alles neu ausgerechnet werden. Um sicherzustellen, dass dieser 1 km Vor-Signal-Abstand, dass man darauf wirklich zum Stehen kommt. Darum geht es nur.
Hauptsache, man kommt in einem Kilometer zum Stehen?
Ja, das ist so. Da gibt es noch andere Details, aber das ist das Grundkonzept. Dass man einfach vor dem Signal schafft, stehen zu bleiben. Sonst wäre es fatal. Es gibt noch einen kleinen Durchrutschweg hinter dem Signal. Da können wir später noch drüber reden. Genau, wenn wir im ersten Bahnhof stehen bleiben müssen. Dann wird erst mal getestet, ob die Bremse funktioniert. Man macht die sogenannte Bremsprobe. Genau. Das ist einfach nur anfahren und wieder bremsen.
Okay, und wenn er bremst, ist es schon mal prima.
Genau, und dann warten wir darauf, dass wir die Streckenfreigabe kriegen.
Da muss ja erst mal diese Schutzweiche sozusagen aufgehoben werden, sonst kommt man ja da nicht hin, wo man hin will.
Man kriegt einen sogenannten Fahrweg geschaltet in die Richtung, in die man gerne möchte. Das heißt, bei Weichen stehen wir in der richtigen Position und die Signale werden dann auch entsprechend, wenn der Fahrweg freigegeben ist, dann auch aufgrün geschaltet von den Weichen. Genau, also die Weichen geschaltet, Signale grün, dann kann man fahren. Und dieser Fahrweg kann auch erst aufgelöst werden, wenn der Zug diesen Block wieder verlassen hat. Man kann nicht einfach so stellen und dann wieder so stellen, sondern es geht erst, wenn der Zug raus ist, und alles andere ist ein ganz großes Drama.
Was heißt geht erst? Also welches Element stellt, dass du sicher, dass das erst angeht?
Es gibt einen Achszähler am Ende des Blockes, der sicherstellt, dass alle Teile des Zuges aus dem Block herausgefahren sind. Also das, was wir vorher meinten, was die Amerikaner mit GPS und Funk machen, um festzustellen, dass der Zug noch komplett ist, das sind bei uns halt kleine Geräte, die halt einfach an den Signalen sind und einfach die Achsen zählen, die über die Schiene fahren. Und dadurch halt ausrechnen können, ist der komplette Zug durchgefahren oder fehlen noch irgendwie viele Achsen. Genau, das war ein Teil dieses, also genau, am Anfang ist erst mal ein Teil dieses Formularausfüllens, dass man auch die Achsen mit reinschreibt. Und das muss eben auch bekannt sein. Und dann werden diese Achsen gezählt. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie genau das läuft. Das ist so ein mechanisches Drucksystem. Hab ich mal gesehen.
Also durch das Überfahren.
Genau, in der Schiene ist einfach ein Gerät angebracht, was die Achsen bezählt, während der Zug drüber fährt. Also keine Laserstrahlen, gar nichts Besonderes.
Das ist auch ganz alt.
Selbst in diesen mechanischen Stellwerken, die mit Drähten, an denen noch gezogen wird, ist es einfach nicht möglich, vordem man die Freigabe von diesem Gerät erhalten hat, die Signal wieder umzustellen. Und gleichzeitig ist es auch so, dass man keinen zweiten Fahrweg legen kann, der halt jetzt diesen anderen Fahrweg kreuzt. Das wird auch mechanisch bei mechanischen Stellwerken auch wirklich absolut durch dich bolzen verhindert, dass ein anderer Fahrweg eingelegt werden kann, der einen anderen Fahrweg kreuzt, der noch nicht aufgelöst ist. Also das ist sehr komplizierte Mechanik da drin.
Was würde denn jetzt zum Beispiel passieren, der unwahrscheinliche Fall, dass jetzt, was weiß ich, da kommen dann so die Bankräuber und springen oben auf den Zug, das kennt man ja aus dem Film, das ist eine tägliche Situation, und koppeln sozusagen den letzten Wagen ab, wo das ganze Geld drin ist. Ja gut, dann brennt es dann sofort.
Der Zug bremst sofort.
Aber in den Wilden Westen, da rollt der noch hinten.
Ja, da haben sie wahrscheinlich keine Druckluftleitung. Das sind zum Teil auch komplett nur lokomotiv gebremste Züge gewesen. Es gibt auch Zeiten, wo halt einfach die Wagen dumm waren. Sie hatten halt, wie gesagt, so Bremswagen, wo Leute drin waren, die signalisiert bekommen.
Haben, durch Pfeifen oder sonst was, dass sie bremsen sollen. Aber würde jetzt sozusagen dieser Zug, also der Wagen, der letzte einfach fehlen und der Zug würde über diesen Axtzähler rüberfahren, dann würde kein anderer Zug in den Block reinkommen.
Genau, der würde weiterhin gesperrt bleiben, würde rot angezeigt bekommen für alle Züge, die darauf folgen. Und dann muss man sich halt gucken, was mit dem Wagen passiert ist. Dann würde quasi dem Stellwerk auffallen, dass der Zug, der Triebfahrzeugführer sich beklagt, dass er keinen Grün kriegt an einer anderen Stelle, aber er noch gar nicht den Block verlassen hat.
Und sind die so robust genug, dass man nicht einfach mit dem Hammer hinkommt und dann irgendwie auf die Teile draufhaut und so Achsensimulationen betreibt?
Also das ist nicht die Zielsetzung dieser Geräte. Also es kann schon sein, dass es da Möglichkeiten gibt. Ja, wahrscheinlich. Also das ist halt so sicherheitstechnisch. Man kann auch halt einfach…
Die Leute mal hier nicht auf schlimme Ideen bringen.
Das ist auch eine Straftat. Also eine richtig schlimme Straftat, ja. Man kann halt auch einfach einen Baumstand auf die Schienen werfen. Das kann ja auch keiner feststellen. Also da hat man auch einfachere Wege.
Ich habe nichts gesagt. Okay, verstehe. Also wir wissen jetzt, wie schwer das Ding ist, vor allem wie viele Achsen das Teil hat. Das wird dann entsprechend gemeldet. Damit ist dieser Zug überhaupt im System und wird sozusagen dann vorgehalten.
Der wird dann quasi vorgehalten.
Den gibt es jetzt. Der hat eine Zugnummer. Man weiß, wo er hin will. Hat einen Fahrplan. Ganz wichtig. So, und wenn er den jetzt auch mal einhalten will, den Fahrplan, dann müsste er nun auch langsam mal in den Bahnhof einlaufen.
Genau. Ja, das...
Altona sagt Bahnhof.
Genau, da muss man sehr langsam reinfahren. Also das ist eigentlich keine großartige Unterschied zum Normalfahren. Also man fährt wahrscheinlich dann auch nach dem Rangierbetrieb im normalen Modus, das heißt wahrscheinlich PZB. Nee, meist fährt man noch in eine Rangierform rein, ich weiß nicht. Kommt darauf an, wie weit die Po und Bahnhof getrennt sind, wahrscheinlich. Genau, darauf kommen wir jetzt. Also das Problem ist, dass man in diesen Sackbahnhof sehr langsam nur einfahren darf. Weil eben am Ende dieser Puffer ist.
Genau, und danach kommt der See.
Genau. Und damit der Lokführer, wie man geht, oder der Triebfahrzeugführer, ich nenne ihn Lokführer, damit der nicht aus Unachtsamkeit heraus oder weil er eingeschlafen ist oder sonst was zu schnell reinfährt, haben wir dafür Technik, die das überwacht. Das heißt, man hat an der Streckenseite Systeme, die dem Zug signalisieren. Wir haben jetzt hier eine Maximalgeschwindigkeit gegeben. Und wenn du die überschreitest, also es gibt da einen gewissen Toleranzbereich, dann wird der Zug zwangsgebremst. So nennt sich das? Das heißt meistens auch, dass es eine Bremsung erfolgt, bis der Zug steht. Und dann muss man halt irgendeine Aktion machen, um diesen Zug überhaupt wieder zum Rollen zu kriegen. Das wird dann komplett entleert. Diese Haftluftdruckleitung wird komplett auf 0 bar runter. Alle Luft wird rausgelassen, damit fallen alle Bremsen zu. Und es wird auch überwacht, dass der Zug zum Stillstand gekommen ist.
Das heißt, das ist sozusagen eine Sicherheitstechnik in der Lok. Er ist in diesem Modus, du darfst nicht schneller fahren als.
Ja, ungefähr, ja.
Und woher weiß er, wann er am Ende auch merken muss, dass er jetzt eigentlich schon stehen sollte. Oder geht es jetzt nur um eine Geschwindigkeitsüberschreitung?
Es geht auch darum, dass der Zug zum kompletten Stillstand gebracht wird. Aber das ist erst mal die Geschwindigkeitsüberschreitung. Genau, das ist das eine Ding. Und wenn man sich jetzt einem Signal nähert, hat man vorher eine gewisse Höchstgeschwindigkeit, sagen wir 120 kmh. Und jetzt hat man ein Signal gekriegt, ein Vorsignal. In einem Kilometer musst du stehen. Und dann muss der Triebfahrzeugführer das Signal quittieren. Er muss sagen, ich habe es gesehen, dass es jetzt rot kommt. Sonst bremst der Zug sofort. Also 4 Sekunden von dem Zeitpunkt an, an dem er die Höhe des Signals überschritten hat. Dann gibt es ein gewisses Bremsprofil, das man einhalten muss. Also man muss die Geschwindigkeit bremsen. So kann man sich das forschen, eine Kurve. Da muss man drunter bleiben. Sonst hätte man zwangsgebremst. Das weiß ich gerade nicht. Es hängt auch von der Art ab. Es gibt verschiedene Induzisysteme. Ganz am Anfang war es so, dass man eine bestimmte Geschwindigkeit nach 20 Sekunden erreicht haben musste. Das war festgesetzt. Das waren damals, glaube ich, 95 kmh. Wenn man ein Vorsignal überfahren hat und das nächste Signal ist rot, 20 Sekunden danach musste man unter 95 kmh sein. Heutzutage ist es eigentlich so, dass es ein Mix ist aus Weg. Die Loktypen früher waren dumm. Die konnten nur einfache Counter realisieren. Heute misst man meistens den Weg und die Zeit, in welcher er in einem bestimmten Profil sein muss. Man kann wirklich komplette Kurven zeichnen und dann muss die Lokmotive auch unterhalb dieser Kurve sein. Ja, genau.
Aber wir wollen ja erst mal in den Bahnhof rein.
Das heißt, wir haben meistens kurz bevor der Bock da ist, haben wir einfach ein Kästchen am Gleis, was aktiv ist, was einfach sagt, wenn du hier drüber fährst, dann mach eine Komplettbremsung. Und das war's.
Das heißt, der Zug dann automatisch?
Genau, aber an sich ist es kein gewollter Zustand. Das ist dann die letzte Sicherung, dass der Zug nicht auffährt. An sich soll der Lokfahrer schon selber sehen, da ist ein weißes Schiff mit einem H drauf. Das ist die Haltetafel. Bis dahin soll er halten, sodass die Passagiere angenehm ein- und aussteigen können.
Aber wenn er es aus welchen Gründen auch immer übersehen sollte, weil er gerade mit James Bond kämpfen muss, dann passiert auch nichts.
Daum und Daum geht es immer bei der Bahn. Es geht nicht darum, Missbrauch zu verhindern, sondern einfach Nachlässigkeit. Genau, einfach im Versehen zu verhindern. Aber man will keinen Lokführer haben. Lokführer, die etwas Böses machen wollen, die würden auch entsprechend...
Ja klar, aber was weiß ich passieren? Der kann ja einen Herzanfall kriegen, er kann irgendwie ohnmächtig werden.
Dagegen gibt es dann noch die Sifa, die Sicherheitsfahrschaltung. Ich weiß nicht, dass man den Tod-Mann-Schaltung nennt. Er muss bei deutschen Bahnen in regelmäßigen Abständen, ich weiß gerade die Zeit... Das ist inzwischen auch Wegezeit. Auch Wegezeit, das wusste ich nicht. Okay, muss man einen Knopf oder einen Fußpedal betreten. Wenn man es nicht macht, gibt es erst ein Lämpchen, das leuchtet. In 200 Sekunden gibt es ein Tonsignal. Wenn man dann nicht reagiert, wird der Zug gebremst. Auch wieder Zwangsbremsung, die man aber aufheben kann, wenn man dann doch betätigt. Das ist halt so um das Leben des Zugfahrers, das schon mal während der Fahrt nicht in irgendwelche Probleme läuft. Und dann noch die Unachtsamkeit, dafür sind dann die Signale da. Also der kann nicht während der Fahrt mal kurz aufs Klo gehen.
In welchem Abstand ist das so üblicherweise?
Also 60 Sekunden bis 30 Sekunden. Es gibt auch weltweit verschiedene Systeme. Es gibt weltweit Sachen, wo man irgendwas nur gedrückt halten muss. Wo Leute auch gerne das Zeug festpappen oder irgendwas draufstellen. In Deutschland ist es so, dass man schon einen Schalter betätigen muss. Also ihn in einer Stellung zu lassen reicht nicht aus. Man muss ihn zumindest toggeln. In der DDR wurde, glaube ich, mit einem Lämpchen signalisiert, dass man den Schalter jetzt betätigen soll und der Abstand zufällig ist. Um sicherzustellen, dass der Mensch nicht eingeschlafen ist. Das höre ich aus dem Schlaf heraus immer. Weil es passiert sehr schnell, dass man im Halbschlaf zu so einer regelmäßigen Handlung in der Lage ist.
Weil man es einfach so gewohnt ist, wie man es immer macht.
Wenn man das acht Stunden am Tag macht, dann so lange fahren sie nicht. Aber wenn man viele Stunden am Tag das macht, dann...
Dann hat man die Routine wahrscheinlich einfach drin.
Ja, genau.
Können jetzt endlich alle einsteigen? Oder müssen wir noch irgendwas bedenken?
Kurz vorm Anhalten muss der Triebfahrzeugführer noch die Türen freigeben. Das macht man üblicherweise kurz vorm Anhalten, weil es auch wieder einen Moment dauert, bis sich das so rumgesprochen hat. Und dann sind die Türen offenbar? Und dann hat der Triebwagenführer nichts mehr zu tun. Dann geht es an den Zugchef oder an den, wie sagt man, Korrekt? Zugchef heißt das, glaube ich, schon. Man kann auch was sagen, Schaffner einfach. Das ist der, der die Türen kontrolliert. Und dann, wie später, werden alle Leute eingestiegen. Also die Türen sicher, glaube ich, die endgültige Sicherstellung ist in der Lokomotive. Das macht der Zugchef. Der Zugchef entscheidet darüber, ob abgefahren werden darf oder nicht. Genau. Und dann wird nur noch verriegelt von der Lokomotive aus. Und wenn dann der Fahrplan sagt, dass man fahren kann und der entsprechende Fahrweg eingestellt ist, das heißt also, die ganzen Signale auf grün stehen, dann kann eigentlich die Zugfahrt beginnen. Genau. Wie man das kennt, da werden alle Türen automatisch geschlossen. Nur die eine nicht, wo der Zugchef dran steht, oder vielleicht mehrere, wenn der Zug länger ist. Und es wird sichergestellt, dass auch nichts mehr los ist, dass keiner da im Gleis ist oder sonst was. Und dann schließen die auch die Türen und dann bleiben die Türen auch zu. Solange nicht die Notüberbrückung aktiviert ist. Und dazu kann er erst mal wieder losfahren.
Und dann Trillerpfeifer.
Trillerpfeifer ist ja das Signal dann auch. Oder Lichtsignal, verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Oder halt über Funk.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die Trillerpfeifer ein gültiges Signal ist.
Na ja, wie auch immer. Es gibt auf jeden Fall einen verbindlichen Rückmeldeweg zum Lokführer, der dann weiß, jetzt kann er auch mal losfahren. Und dann kann er einfach aufs Gas drücken und los geht's.
Ja, da hat er eben keinen Pedal, sondern einen Hebel. Oder wenn er in einem ICE ist oder in einem anderen, moderneren Zug. Gibt da wirklich alles von automatisch? Da kommen wir später auch nochmal vielleicht zu. Können wir auch jetzt machen.
Ja, wenn man nämlich sagt, man kommt da nochmal drauf zu, dann kann man da nie drauf.
Und man LZB hat.
Ihr habt ja noch diese Abkürzung noch nicht erklärt, diese PZB.
Wir haben noch nicht ganz genau erklärt, wie sie funktioniert. Also Punktzug-Beeinflussung ist ein...
Punktzug-Beeinflussung.
Genau, das heißt, wir versuchen den Zug immer an bestimmten Punkten. Das sind irgendwie Blockanfang und Blockende, halt immer zu manipulieren. Und dafür hatten wir ja gesagt, wir haben diese Sachen am Gleis, diese Dinge am Gleis, die versuchen, diesem Zug jetzt irgendwelche Mitteilungen geben, wie er sich verhalten muss. Und das sind an sich drei Bestandteile, das sind drei verschiedene Magneten, das sind elektromagnetisch gesteuerte Schwingkreise, die einmal im 1000 Hertz am Vorsignal liegen. Das heißt also, dieser Schwingkreis ist aktiv und wird von der Lok wahrgenommen. Wenn das Signal auf gelb steht, das heißt also, das nächste Signal wäre rot. Ich habe also 1000 Meter noch, bis ich stehen muss. Dann gibt es nach 750 Metern ein 500-Hertz-Signal, wo dann die nächste Beeinflussung dazu stattfindet. Da steht kein Schild mehr nebendran. Das ist einfach nur zur Sicherheit, um sicherzustellen, dass der Zug wirklich runtergebremst hat. Genau, wir haben diese eine Bremskurve gehabt nach dem ersten. Jetzt müssen wir aufpassen, dass der Zugführer nicht aus dem Simulator beschleunigt hat. Wir haben eine zweite Beeinflussung, wo wir überprüfen, ob der Zug schneller als 45 kmh ist. Und schneller als 60.
Also der Zug überprüft das selber.
Erst kriegt der Zug nicht signalisiert, jetzt musst du bremsen. In diesem folgenden Profil. Das weiß er. Dann kriegt er ein Signal, jetzt kommt das Hauptsignal gleich. Jetzt darfst du auf keinen Fall schneller als 45 mehr fahren. Genau, und dann kommt dann das HP-0. Wenn das nicht tun würde, gibt es die Zwangsfansung. Das ist immer so konzipiert, dass man es nicht schafft, in den Gefahrenbereich reinzurutschen, wenn einer existiert. Es gibt den Unterschied zwischen Schutzsignalen und Blocksignalen. Blocksignal ist nur zur Separierung der verschiedenen Streckenteile. Das Schutzsignal ist vor Weichen oder Ähnlichem. Man kann über das Signal hinausrutschen, das kann man nicht verhindern. Aber es ist sichergestellt, dass man nicht in den Gefahrenbereich kommt. Also nicht auf die andere Strecke kommt. Wir haben ja dieses Lichtraumprofil vorhin gehabt. Es ist sichergestellt, dass es so weit reicht, dass diese Lichtraumprofile bei sich bei einer Weiche nicht schneiden und berühren. Was immer der Zug zum Stehen kommt. 45 kmh ist bei diesem Abstand ausreichend. Dann gibt es auch wieder, dass man runterbremsen muss auf 20 kmh. Man kann höchstens mit 20 kmh über ein rotes Signal fahren. Erst mal, wenn das Signal rot ist, selber am Hauptsignal, wenn das HP0 anzeigt, das zeigt, dass der Zug stehender muss, ist da ein 1000 Hz Schwingkreis. Der sagt einfach, jetzt ist sofort Schluss. Damit wird sofort gebremst, wenn dieser Schwingkreis aktiv ist. Genau. Da man 20 kmh schnell ist und man sichergestellt hat, durch vorher diese Messungen, das Ausrechnen, wie schwer man ist, ist sichergestellt, dass man auf keinen Fall mit einem anderen Zug kollidieren kann. Das ist die Punkt-Zug-Beinflussung. Das reicht eben nicht aus, wenn man schneller als 160 kmh fährt. Das reicht vielleicht schon, aber das ist nicht der Punkt. Genau. Weil festgelegt wurde, dass über 160 kmh kein sinnvoller Betrieb mehr möglich ist. Man hätte so leichte, kurze Züge, die dann noch schaffen würden, zum Stehen zu kommen. Um diese Geschwindigkeitsprofile einzuhalten, wären so starke Beschleunigungen nicht mehr sinnvoll. Und auch die Signale sind irgendwann nicht mehr sinnvoll ablesbar. Die kommen dann sehr schnell auf den Triebfahrzeugführer zu. Das macht es schwierig. Es ist dann auch schwierig geworden, beliebige Geschwindigkeiten voraus dem Zugführer mitzuteilen. Man kann es nicht überprüfen, ob der Zug in der Geschwindigkeit oder in der Geschwindigkeit fährt. Da sind dann so Sachen entstanden, dass es diese Gleisgeschwindigkeits-Prüfabschnitte gibt, die dann z.B. ein 1000-Hertz-Signal scharf schalten, wenn der Zug in der Geschwindigkeit zwei andere Bereiche des Schienen überfahren hat. Es gibt eine kleine Steuerung, die misst, wie lange der Zug von hier zu hier gebraucht und schaltet solange den 1000-Hertz-Magneten scharf. D.h., man hat gar kein Signal da. Es ist nur eine Bremsung, die durch mehrere Messungen überprüft, ob die Geschwindigkeit nicht überschritten wird.
Moment, langsam. Jetzt habe ich es ein bisschen verloren. Dieses ganze Blocksystem ist darauf ausgelegt, erst mal pro Block einen Zug. Das Ganze hat eine gewisse Annahme gehabt, wie Züge normalerweise lang und schwer sind, was sie für Power haben und vor allem, was sie für eine Höchstgeschwindigkeit erreichen. Und die Signale stellen dann halt sicher, wenn also irgendwo ein Wagen hängen geblieben ist, ein Zug einfach stehen geblieben ist und ein Block muss dann mit Rot abgesichert werden, dann schaltet das entsprechende Signal, wo man nicht mehr weiterfahren darf, auf Rot, und das davor schaltet auf Gelb. Und in dem Moment, wo ein anderer Zug rüberfährt, wenn der Zugführer jetzt selber nicht das Signal wahrnimmt, dann gibt es über die Schiene, wird diese Signalinformation in den Zug hinein, nicht über die Schiene, sondern über einen kleinen Kasten an der Seite. Okay, also über die Strecke. Da steht sozusagen ein Schwingkreis, der sozusagen zuverlässig auch einem schnell fahrenden Zug diese Information mitgeben kann, sodass der Zug selber weiß, aha, ich dürfte jetzt maximal so und so schnell sein.
Das Problem ist ja, der Schwingkreis sagt ja nur 1 oder 0. Das ist ja eigentlich eine binäre Sache, die der Schwingkreis sagen kann. Man kann unterscheiden zwischen diesen drei Frequenzen. Also die einzigen...
Also drei Frequenzen.
Genau. Man kann nicht sagen, du darfst jetzt nur 80 fahren oder sowas.
Also im Prinzip signalisiert er nur das Gelb oder Rot.
Genau.
Oder gar nichts.
Also er kann halt einen 1000 Hertz Schwingkreis einschalten, einen 500 Hertz Schwingkreis oder einen 2000 Hertz Schwingkreis.
Und das ist rot, gelb, grün?
Nee, grün ist gar nichts. Das ist eine Einleitung von einer Bremskurve im Zug.
Okay, grün ist gar nichts. Also dann sind es sozusagen drei verschiedene Bremskurven.
Drei verschiedene Bremskurven, die eingegangen werden können.
Sozusagen, wie schnell zum Stehen kommen, irgendwie?
Naja, nicht zum Stehen kommen.
Bremsen.
Eine Bremsprofil A, Bremsprofil B ist dann 500 Hertz und dein 1000 Hertz ist sofort Stillstand.
Okay.
So eine ganz krasse Bremskurve. Genau.
Und dann muss der Zug sozusagen selber gucken, wo er relativ zu dieser Information steht und dann entsprechende Maßnahmen einleiten.
Man hat dann eben diese Probleme, dass man sagt, wir haben jetzt hier eine Kurve, da darf man nur so und so schnell fahren. Und das würden wir gerne kontrollieren, dass das auch der Fall ist. Und da hat man eben angefangen, diese Geschwindigkeits-Prüfabschnitte einzuführen, die geprüft haben, wie schnell kommt der Zug von A nach B. Und wenn das zu schnell ist, wird quasi sofort rot geschaltet. Aber es ist kein Signal da, sondern es hat nur diese Kästen liegen am Boden.
Also jetzt für den Fall, dass die Züge schneller sind?
Genau.
Okay, das ist jetzt sozusagen der neue Fall.
Man kann sich vorstellen, dass ein unsichtbares Signal immer auf Rot ist und erst dann, wenn der Zug schnellstens da sein darf, auf Grün geschaltet. Ah, okay. Das ist deswegen eingefügt worden, weil einfach nicht mehr an Informationen über diese drei Schwingkreise in die Lokomotive befördert werden konnte. Aber das alles reicht nicht, um irgendwie die Zug-Beeinflussung zu machen, die man eigentlich haben will für Hochgeschwindigkeitszüge.
Was fährt denn schneller als 160?
Also jetzt an Bahnprodukten, der Intercity und der Intercity Express.
Nur die beiden.
Gütterzüge haben zum Teil gleichen, Gütterzüge fahren aber eigentlich nicht schneller. Sie könnten, Sie haben die Lokomotiven gleich dafür. Es gibt auch, es gibt auch, ja es gibt einige fahren genau 160, so Regional Express oder so was, aber ich glaube. An sich schon die IC und die IC.
Okay, aber wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, bei 160 Stundenkilometern, da ist sozusagen die Grenze, wo das alte System nicht mehr so unabhängig greift, und warum greift es nicht mehr?
Weil wir die Bremswege nicht mehr einhalten können.
Und warum können wir die Bremswege nicht mehr einhalten?
Weil wir immer noch lange Züge fahren wollen und schwere Züge fahren wollen. Die sind dafür zu schnell. Die sind dann so schnell, dass es nicht mehr klappt einfach. Die können aber in das alte Blockmodell nicht rein. Die Blöcke können nicht variiert werden, sondern die sind einfach mal festgestampft worden, als die steckige geplant wurde. Genau, und da muss man eben in einem Kilometer irgendwie eine ICE3-Doppelgarnitur von 250 auf Null bringen mit 700 Leuten drin. Das ist halt schon unangenehm. Und deswegen hat man eben die LZB, die entsprechende Linienzug-Beeinflussung, wo durchgehend der Zug beeinflusst werden kann. Wo gar keine Signalisierung am Streckenrand mehr stattfindet, sondern nur noch im Fahrzeug selbst. Also man darf sogar keine externen Signalisierungen. Dieses PZB wird malerweise ausgeschaltet, aber man soll es, glaube ich, man darf es auch gar nicht mehr. PZB wird deaktiviert, ja. Genau. Und Signale am Streckenrand sind zu ignorieren.
Ah, das heißt, wenn ein ICE da langrauscht, der informiert sich selbst.
Nicht unbedingt, kommt auf die Strecke an. Das ist eine Strecke.
Wo kriegt er jetzt seine Information her, dass er stehen bleiben muss, wenn es nicht die Strecke selber tut?
Das ist ein kleines Kabel, was in der Mitte ist. Das kann man auch irgendwie häufig sehen an ICE-Bahnhöfen. Das ist so ein kleines Kabel in der Mitte der Gleise, was wie eine Antenne wirkt und einfach Telegramme in den Zug verschickt.
Also es gibt sozusagen nicht mehr den einen Punkt, an dem ein Signal reingereicht wird, sondern es ist eine durchgehende Hineinsignalisierung.
Genau, deswegen die Liniepunkt. Das hat schon irgendwie seine Behandlung. Genau, und das ist da vorhanden, wo die Züge schneller als 160 fahren. Das ist einfach, wenn ICE hier, weiß ich nicht, Heidelberg-Karlsruhe fährt, dann ist es ganz normal, dann fährt er wie alle anderen Züge auch. Was er nicht macht, landwerfnermäßig. Aber auf den Schleiferstrecken wird eben nach LZB gefahren und dann sieht er nur seine Signale in seinem Cockpit. Der Triebwagenführer, der Zug sagt von sich selber, ich fahre jetzt mehr oder weniger LZB, wenn er das entsprechend reaktiviert hat und ab dann kann er sich eigentlich fast zurücklehnen. Also er kriegt dann eine Anzeige, er hat eine Anzeige, wie viele Meter er noch grün hat. Und die aktuelle Säugeschwindigkeit wird ihm ausgerechnet. Genau, die Maximalgeschwindigkeit wird auch ausgerechnet. Es gibt dann sogenannte AFB, das ist die Automatische Fahrbeeinflussung, Fahrtbeeinflussung, weiß nicht. Das heißt, da wird die Geschwindigkeit auch noch reguliert. Das heißt, er stellt ein, was er gerne maximal hätte. Das ist wie ein Tempomat beim Auto. Man kann auch bei PZB AFB aktivieren, das heißt, ich gebe eine Geschwindigkeit vor und der versucht sie einzuhalten. Wenn ich jetzt bei LZB AFB aktiviere, dann kann ich aber Vollgas geben und die LZB sagt dem AFB, wie schnell der Zug maximal fahren darf und fährt komplett automatisch. Also bremst auch automatisch und man muss nur noch siefer betätigen.
Das ist natürlich auch in vielerlei Hinsicht viel effizienter, weil er sozusagen eigentlich immer so das Maximum, was man jetzt noch fahren könnte, auch raushält. Deswegen ist es sozusagen auch so selten geworden, jetzt wenn man mit dem Intercity oder Intercity Express unterwegs ist, dass er wirklich mal stehen bleibt. Aber man kann schon häufiger Geschwindigkeitsvarianten feststellen. Man kann so Stop-and-Go verhindern, das ist sehr ökonomisch wichtig. Beim D-Zug, wenn ich mich so zurück erinnere, da war eigentlich das Stehenbleiben häufiger Teil der Experience.
Es ist auch wichtig, ökonomischer zu fahren.
Na klar.
Man hat halt aber immer noch Blöcke. Unten drunter ist immer noch das gleiche System und diese Blöcke sind immer noch ortsfest. Während in anderen Ländern schon mit dynamischen Blöcken gefahren wird, das heißt, dass jeder Zug so einen Block hinter sich herzieht, wo keiner rein darf, weil er wird auffahren. Aber das ist hier noch nicht zugelassen aus Sicherheitsbedingungen.
Ich verstehe, aber wenn er so einen ICE schnell fährt, dann macht er natürlich nach hinten auch schneller frei.
Normalerweise kommt dann auch ein ICE wieder hinterher.
Dann könnte man wieder dichter packen.
Genau, so könnte man noch ein bisschen dichter packen. Das ist die Motivation. Das gibt es, glaube ich, sogar schon in Industrie. Also wenn große Firmen, wie zum Beispiel Gasproppen, glaube ich, die fahren sogar auch schon mit solchen Systemen, sodass die halt komplett eigene Eisenbahnnetze haben, die verwenden zum Taschen solche Systeme. Aber keine Passagiere drunter?
Gasproppen hat ein eigenes Eisenbahnnetz. Die sind ziemlich groß. Ich wusste gar nicht, das führt man da jetzt.
Es gibt, glaube ich, sogar ganze Städte, die deswegen nur existieren. Da würde ich immer ganz klar unterscheiden. Security und Safety. Es ist mehr Safety.
Okay, da hast du sehr recht. Die schöne Doppeldeutlichkeit des Wortes.
Das haben wir im Deutschen nicht so.
An der Stelle ist es wirklich Safety. Wo waren wir denn jetzt mit unserem Zug stehen geblieben?
Wir sind gerade losgefahren. Wir sind vom ersten Bahnhof.
Ich glaube, da war ein rotes Signal. Also wir können sozusagen jetzt so lange fahren, wie uns kein rotes Signal liegt. Beziehungsweise wenn wir jetzt in Intercity sind, gehen wir mal davon aus, wir sind jetzt in Intercity und fahren da irgendwie mit 180 irgendwie lang. Dann folgen wir im Prinzip dem Kabel. Das liegt so zwischen den Schienen und sagt uns die ganze Zeit, wie schnell wir fahren dürfen und wenn da irgendwo ein bisschen was unklar ist und da kommt ein Zug nicht richtig in Wallungen, dann fahre ich vielleicht mal für ein paar Kilometer, zehn Stundenkilometer langsamer.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das jetzt in Produktivbetrieb genau aussieht, aber das ist möglich.
Es scheint mir jetzt wieder der Weg zu sein. Und wenn dann irgendwie klar ist, ah, jetzt ist er wieder weg, jetzt hat er da, was weiß ich, die richtige Weiche genommen und jetzt ist wieder viel Platz, dann kann man auch volle Punde fahren und dann wird dann entsprechend automatisch oder eben durch den Zugführer Gas gegeben. Und ja, so ist eigentlich alles super. Und dann kommt man irgendwann beim nächsten Zug, beim nächsten Bahnhof an und hält und fährt wieder weiter und hält und fährt wieder weiter und alles war super.
Ja, das ist jetzt auch immer das gleiche Konzept eigentlich, also so mit abgedeckt, ja. Und irgendwann am Ende wird der Zug dann aufgelöst und das ist quasi der gleiche Prozess andersrum, man wird sich irgendwie auf dem Rangierfeld abgestellt.
In anderen Ländern ist das aber anders.
Es gibt einige Länder, wo auch richtig Dispatching-Betrieb gefahren wird. Das heißt, dass gar nicht klar ist, an welchem Bahnsteig ein Zug abfährt, in Frankreich zum Beispiel. Aber nur im Nahverkehrsnetz? Ja, steht man in der Bahnhofshalle und wartet, bis auf der Anzeigetafel der Zug angezeigt wird und dann steht da auch angezeigt, auf welchen Gleis der kommt. Ist halt flexibler, aber ist halt für die Fahrgäste nicht so komfortabel vielleicht. Ja, genau, dafür ist dann ganz krass abgetrennt das TGV-Netzwerk, was dann wirklich komplett eigene Gleisen hat, was komplett wirklich dann auch nur auf bestimmten Plattformen am Bahnhof halten kann und wo auch dann die Gleisen noch mal krasser als bei den deutschen Hochgeschwindigkeitsstrecken komplett isoliert sind. Da ist meistens dann wirklich noch mal ein dicker Zaun drumherum, dass so was wie zu schlau diese Schafe im Tunnel nicht passieren können.
Das heißt, das ist auch ein Grund, warum der so schnell fahren konnte. Weil er einfach seine eigene Trasse hat.
Genau, der kriegt auch höhere Durchschnittsgeschwindigkeiten hin, weil der einfach auf keinen anderen Zug rücksichtigen nehmen muss. Wenn es vor dem ICE ein Güterzug ist, dann muss der hinten dran fahren. Genau, es gibt so zwei Ansätze, ein schnelles Netz hochzuziehen. Der eine Ansatz ist, man hat keine bestehende Infrastruktur. Die bestehende Infrastruktur ist so marode, dass man es einfach bleiben lässt, die weiter zu nutzen. Und zieht komplett ein neues Netz hoch, wie es die Franzosen gemacht haben. Oder die Japaner ja auch. Sie haben auch teilweise alte Netze mitbenutzt, aber gegen Ende haben sie nur noch neue aufgebaut. Und in Deutschland hat man sich, weil man so ein großes Netz schon hatte, entschieden, dass man möglichst schnell auf den bestehenden Netzen fahren will. Und dann so sporadisch Stück für Stück das auszubauen. Und deswegen war da ein ganz anderer Fokus. Wir haben auch Neigertechnik-Züge, die dann auch sogar im Regionalverkehr mit Diesel-Lokomotiven, zum Beispiel in Nürnberg, Dresden, häufig gefahren sind. Das ist nicht so häufig überall zu finden. Die meisten bauen dann einfach die Strecken neu aus. Die Schweden zum Beispiel, die haben sich auch sehr viel auf Neigertechnik und ähnliche Dinge gesetzt und wollen einfach das bestehende Netz weiter nutzen. Die fahren dann immer, weil es auch eine Neubastrecke zwischen diesen so weit entfernten Städten nicht so leicht möglich ist. Und die fahren halt 200 nur, statt 330, was die Franzosen jetzt gerade fahren. Aber von den Ökonomischen her war es einfach der Plan, der für sie am besten aufgegangen ist.
Neigertechnik bringt uns ja auch noch zum anderen Punkt. Neigertechnik ist quasi der Versuch, schneller in Kurven zu fahren, indem man sich hinein neigt. Das meint es ja. Da gibt es ja auch einen speziellen ICE, der das macht.
Was gibt es sogar?
Regenalbahn würde das machen. Ja, aber es gibt den ICE-3, oder wie der heißt? Ich dachte, er hat noch einen speziellen Namen. Ich dachte auch der ICE-T. Das ist Berlin, München. Berlin, München, die Thüringer Berge etc. ICE-T, genau, das war es.
Ja, das hat technisch immer so ein gewisses Problem mit diesem System. Es hat häufiger Ausfälle gehabt und diversen Modelle. Es liefen auch teilweise gar nie in einem richtigen Dauerbetrieb. Es ist halt alles nicht so einfach. Es gibt im Prinzip mehrere Stufen der Neigetechnik. Die simpelste Stufe der Neigetechnik ist die sogenannte Gleisüberhöhung. Dass man einfach die eine Seite des Gleises in der Kurve höher baut als die andere. Das merkt man dann, wenn der Zug mal in der Kurve stehen bleibt.
Aber wie steht denn der Zug überhaupt auf den Schienen? Ich meine, Räder waren ja nun auch gerade in den letzten Jahren ein heißes Thema in der ganzen Bahntechnik. Wie wird dafür gesorgt, dass der Zug da nicht entgleist? Wie hält er sich denn überhaupt?
Wenn man so ein Lein erstmal ein Rad eines Schienensfahrzeuges malen lässt, dann macht er eigentlich zwischen den sogenannten Spurkranz, dass es das Stück, was an der Seite des Rades übersteht und verhindert, dass der Zug abrutscht, vom Gleis runterrutscht. Das Ding, was immer quietscht, wenn man Züge hört. Das, wo der Zug aufliegt, in rechten Winkel dazwischen. Aber das ist nicht so, weil das wäre unglaublich laut und würde ganz zeitfunkend schlagen und die Räder würden kaputtgehen. Sondern das ist ein größerer Winkel. Das heißt, dass die Räder, so konusförmig ist das richtige Wort, sind und der Zug so ein bisschen hin und her eiert auf den Schienen. Er pendelt so hin und her. Es ist eine sinusförmige Bewegung, die der Zug letztendlich im Gleisbett durchführt. Nur in Kurven, die sehr eng sind und eigentlich zu schnell gefahren werden, stößt der Spurkranz an die Schiene ran. Dann gibt es dieses quietschende Geräusch. Normalerweise gibt es eben dadurch, dass es da höher geht auf diesem Rad, allein durch die Schwerkraft wird es dann ausgeglichen und verhindert, dass es dann...
Ah, verstehe. Das heißt, der Zug ist eigentlich gar nicht so auf der Schiene, sondern schwimmt eigentlich. Er schwimmt auf der Schiene.
Ganz genau.
Schwapper, was für den Komfort dann sozusagen auch ganz hilfreich eigentlich ist. Ganz sehr, sehr hilfreich, ja. Okay, aber die Belastung ist natürlich enorm auf diesen Rädern.
Die Belastung ist natürlich enorm.
Aus was werden die so gebaut?
Also generell ist es Stahl, aber es gibt dann so spezielle Legierungen. Gibt es da die Diskussion um diese Radreifen bei dem ICE? Das waren dann nur irgendwelche speziellen Legierungen, die draufgelegt wurden mit dem anderen Stahl.
Also bei dem ICE, wir reden jetzt von dieser großen Katastrophe in, wie hieß noch der Wort gleich? Eschede. Eschede, genau.
Da hat sich dieser Radreifen gelöst und da ist scheinbar diese Verbindung zwischen diesen.
Aber wo ist denn dieser Reifen drauf?
Das ist wie beim Auto. Das ist einfach auf dem Rad drauf, ist halt ein Metall auf einem anderen Metall. Also das sieht man jetzt nicht so.
Ja gut, aber wenn das da sozusagen so rund ist, also über die volle Fläche oder nur da, wo wirklich jetzt der Kontakt besteht.
Da, wo Kontakt besteht. Die Lauffläche. Die Lauffläche. Da ist das drauf.
Das heißt, dieser Radreifen macht dann aber auch diese Bewegung sozusagen. Also auch sozusagen so ein rund...
Ja, das ist genau das Gleiche, nur dass es eben an der Oberfläche ein anderes Material ist als im Inneren.
Und warum war das so?
Wahrscheinlich ist es ein Kostenfaktor. Oh, Reibung, das weiß ich wirklich nicht.
Okay, also es gab irgendeinen Grund.
Genau.
Und was war das Problem?
Das Problem war, dass sich das wohl irgendwie gelöst hat und dann die Weiche umgestellt wurde, die kurz vor der Brücke war, durch dieses Teil, was abstand, das auch irgendwie wohl durch den Boden eines Waggons geschlagen ist, wo dann aber wohl keiner die Notbremse betätigt hat.
Also der Radreifen ist abgesprungen.
Ja genau. Hat irgendwas an der Weiche getriggert? Und dadurch, dass das ein Teil herumhing, wurde an der Weiche umgestellt, der hintere Teil des Zuges ist entgleist und ist in die Brücke rein geknallt und dann gab es diesen Accordeon-Effekt. Und der vordere Teil des Zuges, ich glaube, das war noch ein älterer ICE, das heißt im Prinzip auch nur Lokomotiven vorne dran und eine Lokomotive nur, und zwar hinten vorne eine bei dem ICE. Und der ist weitergefahren, ganz normal und wurde halt dann zwangsgebremst, wie wir jetzt gelernt haben. Aber er wusste, also dadurch, dass die Leitungen leer waren, weil die Waggons abgerissen waren, aber er wusste gar nicht, was los war, der Triebfahrzeugführer. Hatte gar nichts von mitgekriegt. Und ich glaube, den ersten Waggon hat es auch nicht so gewusst, weiß ich nicht mehr genau. Und das Problem war eben, dass hinter dieser Weiche diese Brücke war. Und man hat eben daraus gelernt, und bei neuen Bauten der Art ist es halt verboten, dass eine Weiche unmittelbar vor der Brücke ist. Genau, damit selbst wenn da ein Zug entgleist, damit dieser Effekt nicht passiert. Das Problem war natürlich ein ganz anderes, das ursprüngliche Problem, dass eben so was überhaupt passieren kann, dass der Radreifen sich lösen kann, was dann wohl irgendwie Wartungsschwierigkeiten auch waren und so weiter. Und dafür gibt es eigentlich eine Kontrollinstanz, das ist eben das Eisenbahnbundesamt. Und die gibt es wirklich. Nur ich weiß noch, für's Eigentlich wollte ich nur... Achso, also eigentlich sollte diese Kontrollinstanz, die ist halt dafür zuständig zu bewachen, dass die Wartung ordnungsgemäß durchgeführt wird. Aber sie hat natürlich auch nur begrenzt, kann nicht immer daneben stehen. Und das ist halt so ein bisschen das Problem, was eben so eine Gratisierung auch irgendwo mit sich führt, dass versucht wird, Kosten zu sparen, wo es geht. Und das ist ein bisschen... Ja, also wir reden hier über das Eisenbahnbundesamt, was eigentlich gar nicht wirklich viele Mitarbeiter hat, sondern halt einen Großteil eigentlich nur als Consultants auch wieder einkauft und dann sagt, wie bitte macht jetzt hier... 20.000 Mitarbeiter hat das, glaube ich. Aber ich glaube, sehr viele davon sind extern oder so, unter längeren Verträgen. Und die werden halt losgeschickt und müssen dann halt stichprobemäßig dann kontrollieren, dass die ganzen Bestimmungen nicht eingehalten werden. Und genau, da hat es leider dann irgendwie nicht gegriffen. Ja, es ist halt auch immer nur, kann nur stichprobenartig gemacht werden. Und da gibt es halt immer diese Selbstverantwortung dieser Betriebe. Und das läuft natürlich komplett gegen den Profitmaximierungsgedanken. Und da kann halt so was passieren. Und es gab es halt häufiger das Problem. Es wurden halt auch, glaube ich, Normen nicht eingehalten, die von dem Hersteller aufgetragen wurden und so weiter. Also es waren Probleme auf vielen Seiten. Es ist häufig bei so Unglücken, dass immer viele Sachen zusammenkommen. Das eben das mit dem Sonar an der Brücke ist, was man auch nicht gewusst hat, dass es ein Problem sein kann. Und das Potenzial ist natürlich immer noch groß, dass es irgendwo anders wieder Schwierigkeiten sein kann.
Aber eigentlich passiert ja doch recht wenig. Dafür, dass einfach so viel schweres Metall da unterwegs ist mit so vielen Menschen.
Ja, die meisten Unglücke, die passieren, sind auch eher kleiner. Und die passieren dann, wenn Sicherungstechnik deaktiviert wird. Es gibt halt häufig, dass ein Signal nicht funktioniert. Dann springt es auch erst mal auf rot alles. Weil das ist so der Standardzustand, erst mal nichts machen. Und dann kann man auch befehlen. Das heißt, der Mensch, der im Stellwerk sitzt, der Fahrdienstleiter, der Fahrdienstleiter teilt mit, ja, du darfst jetzt trotzdem fahren. Das war lange Zeit einfach wirklich ein schriftlicher Befehl, der halt in die Lokomotive gebracht werden musste. Woraufhin dann dieser...
Schriftlich. Die schicken dir ja einen Fax oder was.
Auto vorbeifahren und halt reinreichen. Aber das ist heute nicht mehr so. Also man kann, so ein Datentelegramm wird halt gesendet. Und erst dann darf man drüber fahren. Aber da es da wirklich nur Menschen dafür zuständig sind, kann es halt da wieder vermehrt zu Problemen kommen. Und da gab es auch mehrfach Frontalzusammenstöße von Zügen auf einstreckigen, eingleisigen Abschnitten. Also da eigentlich immer regelmäßig nachgebessert. Also auch zum Beispiel bei den Sachen, wo, ich weiß nicht, wie das war, noch Regionalverkehr oder vielleicht sogar S-Bahn-Verkehr, der noch mit PZB gefahren ist, war es häufig so, dass Leute mit einem roten Signal halt zum Halten gebracht wurden an einem Bahnhof. Dann aber beim Abfahrtsignal nicht mehr auf das rote Signal geachtet, und dann einfach losgefahren sind. Und das rote Signal einfach damit ignoriert haben. Und dann wurde zum Beispiel auch eingeführt, dass dann in späteren Versionen von PZB dann, wenn ein Zug so lange in dieser niedrigen Geschwindigkeit gefahren ist, dann schalte ich in besonders restriktiven Modus rein. Da muss ich erst daraus befreien, dass er schnell wieder weiterfahren darf. So was wird immer sehr schnell nachgepflegt, wenn solche Sachen aufgetreten sind. Genau, das ist auch eben Aufgabe des Eisenbahnbundesamtes, zu überprüfen, was man noch besser machen kann. Es gibt immer zwangsweise Gutachten dazu. Wo sind überall die Probleme? Auch wenn offensichtlich ein Mensch den Fehler gemacht hat, wird analysiert, wie konnte es überhaupt dazu kommen, dass dieser Fehler passieren kann? Und wo kam da Routine rein, die gefährlich ist? Also kriegt z.B. der Lokführer jedes Mal, wenn er an diesem Signal ist, immer einen manuellen Weiterfahrbefehl, hat er sich schon dran gewöhnt, dann achtet er auch nicht mehr so stark drauf, als wenn das wirklich mal zweit oder dreimal im Jahr für ihn passiert, und es für ihn so ein außergewöhnliches Ereignis ist, wo er dann Adrenalin hat und wirklich aufpasst, dass auch jetzt keine Dokumotive entgegenkommt. Genau, es ist seine Aufgabe, sein Fehler, aber nichtsdestotrotz wird immer noch analysiert, wie Contest dazu kommt, ähnlich wie im Luftverkehr auch.
Wie muss man sich jetzt eigentlich diese Planung des Netzes vorstellen? Also es gibt überall Gleise, manchmal gibt es irgendwie nur eins, manchmal gibt es zwei, was nicht wie breit so eine Verbindung zwischen zwei Städten ausfallen kann. Sind auch mal vier Gleise, sechs Gleise, ist das wie bei der Autobahn?
Kann durchaus vorkommen. Normalerweise werden zwei Gleisen verlegt, die dann im Gleiswechselbetrieb, also die halt quasi von beiden Richtungen auch befahren werden können. Das heißt also, es werden auf beiden Seiten, jeweils beide Richtungen, Signale aufgebaut, alles Mögliche. Und dann auch entsprechend die Möglichkeiten für Überholmanöver vorbereitet, dass er so einen Zug überholen kann. Meist auch innerhalb von Bahnhöfen einfach. Das heißt, ein Regionalzug hält an dem Bahnhof X, reicht aus auf Gleis 3 in diesem Bahnhof und auf Gleis 2 fährt dann schnell der andere Zug durch. Und das ist ganz normalen Fahrplan integriert. So genannte Überholstellen gibt es auch noch. Das heißt, auf freier Strecke genau das gleiche Manöver. Mehr für Güterzüge interessant. Oder für außerplanmäßige Überholungen, wenn der Regionalzug Verspätung hat oder der schnelle Zug. Damit der Betrieb nicht so sehr eingeschränkt wird, wenn das häufiger vorkommen kann. Vielleicht können wir mal kurz zurückspringen. Wir haben ja gesagt, wir haben eine Maximallänge von Zügen von 57 Metern. Wenn man dann solche Überholspuren plant und so Sachen, das läuft alles mit rein, wenn man jetzt wirklich hergehen möchte, man möchte auf 1,5 Kilometer Güterzüge hoch, dann müsste man halt schon das komplette Bahnnetz noch mal umkrempeln und diese ganzen Überholstellen vergrößern, was dann ein sehr grosser Aufwand wäre.
Das lässt sich gar nicht mal so eben machen. Nee, das ist wirklich groß.
Wenn man sowas plant, dann muss man schon viel Geld in die Hand nehmen. Meistens auch irgendwelche, also es ist halt problematisch, weil früher die Bahnstrecken häufig auf die grüne Wiese gebaut wurden und mittlerweile halt dann Städte sich darum entwickelt haben. Machen die Franzosen ja auch heute noch? Ja, das ist auch einfacher, muss man sagen. Das Problem ist, dass man eben in Deutschland auch eine hohe Bevölkerungsdichte hat und dann muss man ganz viele Leute zwangsenteignen und solche Sachen. Das ist nicht so einfach, das sind sehr langfristige Verfahren. Bei der Bahn ticken die Uhren eh alle ein bisschen langsamer. Das heißt, man ist sehr vorsichtig im Adaptieren von neuen Technologien, was jetzt solche, was das Gesamtnetz betrifft, weil es halt einfach extrem teuer ist, das auszurollen auf dem ganzen Netz. Und auch bei Baustellen, wenn man hier Frankfurt-Köln sich anguckt, das wurde Jahrzehnte vorher angefangen zu planen. Da hat man sich so angeschaut, wie viel Steigung können wir reinbauen? Was geben denn in den 20 Jahren, wenn wir das fertiggestellt haben, die Lokomotiven her?
Was ist Frankfurt-Köln?
Das ist dieses Schnellfahrstreckenausbau. Die hat eine ungewöhnlich hohe Steigung von 40 Promille. Da kann momentan nur die ICE3 drauf fahren, weil die Steigung so hoch ist.
Weil das die Einzigen sind, die das überhaupt bewältigen können?
Genau.
Was qualifiziert die ICE3?
Die sind sehr stark pro Achse. Sie haben, glaube ich, 16 Achsenmotoren. Das ist auf die ganze Zuglänge schon relativ viel, sodass er beschleunigen kann. Wahrscheinlich muss er trotzdem häufig noch Sand sprühen. Die anderen ICEs würden da auch hochkommen. Das Problem ist nur, wenn sie stehen bleiben, würden sie nicht mehr anfahren können. Der ist nicht stärker insgesamt. Nur die Räder würden dann durchdrehen, wenn man zu stark Gas gibt. Weil die Reibung zwischen Stahl auf Stahl ist nicht so. Das ist auch das alte Gummi-Aufwalt.
Was ist der Unterschied? Beim ICE gibt es noch einen normalen Triebzug vorne. Der ICE3 hat das über die ganze Länge verteilt.
Das ist ein Vierrad-Antrieb beim Auto, im Gegensatz zu einem Heck-Antrieb oder so was. Genau. Der ICE1, wie man ihn nennt, kann man sich eigentlich forschen. Es sind zwei Lokomotiven, eine vorne, eine hinten, die eine schöne aerodynamische Verkleidung außenrum haben. Und Waggons, die fest aneinander gekoppelt sind und Druckübergänge haben. Das heißt, es ist künstlicher Druck drin.
Damit, wenn man mit hoher Geschwindigkeit in den Tunnel fährt, die Ohren nicht zufallen.
Genau.
Beziehungsweise auch, wenn ein anderer Zug an einem vorbeifährt.
Ich hatte mal das Vergnügen, in Schweden mit einem Experin-Tellen-Zug zu fahren. Die haben einen Versuchsträger für verschiedene Technologien, die die haben. Weil es eben nur ein Versuchszug war, haben sie keine Druckertüchtigung, wie man es bei der Bahn hier nennt, drin gehabt. Und dann sind wir halt mit 200 in den Tunnel gefahren. Und dann kam dann noch ein anderer Zug und das war schon abenteuerlich.
Abenteuerlich?
Ja, das war schon...
Tat weh oder was?
Ja, war einfach sehr unangenehm, hat schon richtig geknallt so. Das ist nicht schön. Also das ist ganz wichtig, dass das der Fall ist, dass man diese Druckkabine da drin hat. Genau, und die Wagen sind fester gekoppelt an. Das kann man nicht einfach so rausnehmen. Ansonsten ist es aber ein ganz normaler Zug, wie Intercity es auch wäre.
Der ICE ist deshalb schneller gewesen, weil er einfach überhaupt schneller fahren konnte, weil er eben nicht diese Limitierung in Bezug auf Aerodynamik und Druck hatte.
Also erst mal ist ICE an sich einfach nur so ein Produktname. Die haben keine Gemeinsamkeit. Das ist glaube ich eher fast so ein Konsortiumname von verschiedenen Herstellern, die halt einfach an diesem Traum sind.
Ich meine, der ICE überhaupt erst mal auf den Markt kam und der erste Zug war, ich meine, der fuhr ja schon deutlich schneller.
Es gibt halt, ja genau, der Unterschied ist, dass er sehr schnell im normalen Einsatz fährt. Es gibt halt diese Lokomotiven, die vorne an der Intercity dranhängen, die sind gar nicht groß anders als die am ICE. Die könnte das auch. Aber die haben auch Linien zu LCB-Support drin, die haben auch Höchstgeschwindigkeiten von 220 kmh, die kommen da schon gut ran. Es gibt halt auch einen Zug, das war so ein Versuchsträger auch so, aber der im Produktivbetrieb war, das war der Metropolitan. Das war ein Druckübergang an einander gekoppelter Intercity quasi, mit der Lok, die heute auch an Intercity dran ist. Und der ist dann auch im ICE-Betrieb übernommen worden. Ich glaube, der fährt heute noch als ICE zwischen Hamburg und Berlin. Ich bin nicht so sicher.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Ruhrgebiet. Das war bis vor ein paar Jahren ein Fahrplanwechsel, glaube ich. Aber der fährt quasi als ICE. Das ist einfach nur so ein künstlicher Name. Aber eben diese Aerodynamik bringt natürlich einen großen Vorteil. Bei der Geschwindigkeit ist das natürlich sehr wesentlich. Und diese Lok, wie man sie so kennt, klassisch ist nicht sonderlich aerodynamisch.
Und der ICE 2?
Der ICE 2 hat nur eine Lok und einen Steuerwagen an der anderen Seite. Sonst unterscheidet es sich auch nicht groß.
Was heißt das, dass er nur in eine Richtung fahren kann?
Nö, da kann er in beide Richtungen fahren. Nur auf der einen Seite ist ein Antrieb.
Das heißt, er schiebt oder zieht. Das ist egal.
Das ist wie beim Intercity, wo man auf der einen Seite auch einen Steuerwagen hat und auf der anderen Seite die Lokomotive hängt und er kann trotzdem in beide Richtungen fahren. Dann wird einfach die Lokomotive fangesteuert von der anderen Seite. Deshalb ist es kürzer in der Standardkoppelung, weil man kann irgendwie zueinander koppeln. Das ist so der Unterschied. Es ist einfach kein großer Unterschied. Der Dreier, der hat dann richtig quasi die Lokomotive auseinandergebaut worden und auf den gesamten Zug verteilt. Das heißt, wir haben einen Wagen, wo die Transformatoren drin sind und die Antriebe dann verteilt auf mehrere Wagen, auf mehrere Achsen. Also es ist nicht überall, aber auf mehrere verteilt. Und das ist halt von der Beschleunigung her deutlich besser.
Weil?
Weil man eben alle gleichzeitig antreiben kann und nicht vorne die Reibung von einem Achsensatz oder mehreren Achsen beschränkt ist, sondern es eben gleichmäßiger verteilt ist.
Das heißt, der kommt auch schneller in die Puschen?
Ganz genau.
Was ja auch noch ein grundsätzliches Problem ist, ne?
Deswegen ist es halt bei Nahverkehrszügen, bei neueren auch überall so wie bei dem ICE. Also wenn man sich hier die... Also Niederflurwagen bestehen auch eigentlich daraus. Weil die Baureihe 425, die jetzt zumindest hier in Süddeutschland sehr populär sind, die sind diese... Als S-Bahn fahren die hier, das ist so ein Niederflurwagen. So ein Schmuckl-Wagen zumindest.
Also man kann sagen, das ist sozusagen ein Trend in der Bahntechnik, dass man einfach das jetzt sozusagen verteilt.
Man hat halt das Problem, dass man die nicht leicht auseinanderkoppeln kann, weil da sehr viel natürlich zusammenhängt zwischen denen. Und die haben halt ein eigenes Stromnetz intern. Also meistens haben die Züge dann intern auch mal ein Gleichstromnetz, wo halt dann die Transfermotoren quasi ein internes Stromnetz bespeisen, an dem halt alle Elektromotoren hängen. Und das ist eigentlich schon, wenn man halt hohe Beschleunigung haben möchte, eigentlich umgänglich sowas in die Richtung zu kommen. Deswegen fährt man die meist in nicht ganz so langen Verbänden, aber dann mehrere aneinander. So dass man dynamisch je nach Bedarf dann unterschiedlich lange Züge machen kann. Also in den Randzeiten kürzere, dann lässt man einfach einen in der Bahnhof stehen, irgendwo, und in den Stoßzeiten dann mehrere.
Das heißt, der ICE3 ist eigentlich überhaupt erst, sagen wir mal, gute Revolution ist vielleicht das falsche Wort, aber stellt sozusagen eine signifikante technische Veränderung des ursprünglichen E-Triebwagen-Konzepts dar. Und das war dann aber auch der erste, oder war das auch schon vorher bei den Straßenbahnen?
Das war schon vorher, das ist nichts wirklich Neues. In der Vollbahn, also in der richtig weit verbrateten Eisenbahn in Deutschland zumindest, das ist schon das erste Mal. Deutschland ist das erste Mal aus dem Fernverkehr so was eingesetzt. Es gab früher noch mal so Ausnahmerscheidungen, aber das ist der erste relevante.
Es ist nicht so, man kennt das so von Strecken, was weiß ich, hier zwischen München und Stuttgart zum Beispiel, da fährt der ICE, da fährt der Intercity tatsächlich ein paar Minuten schneller als ein Intercity-Express.
Ja, der Intercity kann halt auch 200 kmh fahren im Regelbetrieb, wenn die Strecke nicht auf mehr Auskühlung ist.
Aber ist der leichter als ein ICE und deswegen kann er besser beschleunigen?
Das sind Fahrplan-Sachen. Ja, das würde ich auch sagen, also zumal da wahrscheinlich auch die gleichen Halte sind. Ich kenne die Strecke jetzt nicht so genau, von daher ist das wirklich noch...
Ich hatte nur gehört, dass der Intercity-Express länger braucht, um auf dieselbe Geschwindigkeit zu kommen.
Ja, die Intercitys sind normal auch sehr schwer, also sehr schwer, das weiß ich jetzt nicht. Also die ICE ist ganz ein, also okay. Ich würde immer schätzen, vom Gefühl her, dass es eher eine Fahrplan-Sache ist. Zumal die meiste Zeit ja noch in einer normalen Geschwindigkeit gefahren ist, also ich nehme nicht an, dass es da eigentlich ist.
Also der ICE ist eigentlich gar nicht so toll.
Doch, doch, das ist schon eine schöne Sache, aber es ist natürlich jetzt nicht irgendwie... Das ist viel auch immer so eine Nationalstolz-Sache, dass wir haben jetzt hier den Neuesten und Besten und sonst was, aber im Prinzip, es geht einfach mehr um so eine ganze Konzeptfrage und dass das ganze Konzept stimmig ist. Der ICE ist nicht der Zug, um alle zu knechten, sondern es ist einfach nur ein Konzept für einen bestimmten Einsatzzweck und der ist nicht für alle Einsatzzwecke geeignet. Man kann nicht jedes Problem mit diesem ICE-Totschlagen. Das wird halt gerne dann so ein bisschen so präsentiert, genauso wie es ist in Frankreich mit dem TGV. Das ist auch eine nationale Sache natürlich, das wird viel staatlich subventioniert, da will man das natürlich auch im Staat halten, die Investitionen. Das funktioniert auch nur mit Staat. Genau, deswegen gibt es ja auch diesen großen Aufschrei momentan in Frankreich über den potenziellen Einsatz von Vilaro, also ICEs, von Siemens in dem Tunnel zwischen Großbritannien und Frankreich, weil das halt klassische französische Domäne ist. Dann, inwieweit das jetzt wirklich in Erwägung gezogen wird oder ob das nun ein Politikum ist von der Betreiberfirma, um als Dom den Hersteller des TGVs unter Druck zu setzen, ist natürlich eine andere Frage. Aber das ist eine absolute nationale Streitfrage, sowas.
Ja, aber wie ist denn der Wettbewerb in dieser Hochgeschwindigkeitstechnik? Ich meine, man kann sagen, das ist ja jetzt alles nichts Besonderes, aber ich meine, es kommt jetzt auch nicht jedes Jahr ein neues Hochgeschwindigkeitszug raus, sondern es ist ja eine lange Entwicklung und da muss einiges getestet werden, wie er auch dieser Unfall gezeigt hat, das hat alles so seine Chancen und Risiken. Wie viele Hochgeschwindigkeitszugkonzepte stehen denn so miteinander in Konkurrenz weltweit? Ich meine, die Japaner haben ja auch noch irgendwie ein System. Ich weiß nicht, wer sonst noch mit dem Spiel ist.
Es hat immer die Frage, wo beginnt die Hochgeschwindigkeit? Das ist halt Höchstgeschwindigkeit. In Österreich hat es ja auch, sagen sie, Hochgeschwindigkeitszüge, die halt wie in Budapest fahren. Das sind halt auch meistens dann 220 kmh. Wenn man jetzt PZB sagt, ab 160 kmh ist Hochgeschwindigkeit, oder wenn man sagt, man hat ab LZD Hochgeschwindigkeit, ist das halt irgendwie schwer zu definieren. Also man kann definitiv sagen, dass es da eigentlich drei Länder gibt, die weltweit führend sind. Das ist halt, aus meiner Sicht, Deutschland, Frankreich und die Japanen nicht unbedingt in dieser Reihenfolge. Und der Rest ist halt Technologietransfer oder Kauf von Technologien schon. Wir haben in Russland jetzt auch ICE-Garnituren am Fahren. Zwischen Sankt Petersburg und Moskau. In China werden auch inzwischen schon die Siemens-Garnituren eingesetzt. Also das greift ein bisschen um sich. Und der TGV wird dann... War das nicht Monaco? Was ist denn Frankreich?
Casablanca?
Nein, nicht Monaco.
Marokko meinst du?
Genau, die bauen sich ein komplettes Hochgeschwindigkeitsnetz jetzt auf in Marokko.
Ja, mit TGV-Technik.
Scheinbar. Also das ist noch nicht so weit. Aber ich glaube, mit diesen Doppelstock-TGVs, das bietet halt Siemens nicht. Da sind sie auch alleine, glaube ich. Bin ich nicht sicher. Weil sie auch nicht. Die Italiener, die haben da auch... Man muss ja auch bedenken, dass so ein Zug immer aus ganz vielen verschiedenen Subsystemen besteht und das auch nicht unbedingt... Es sind immer Konsortien. Italiener haben so ihre eigenen Vorzüge. Die fahren inzwischen statt mit dem Nachfolger mehr oder weniger schon von LZB, was jetzt europaweit generalisiert wird, haben aber dann jetzt momentan nicht so die berühmte Hochgeschwindigkeitstechnologie. Könnten aber jetzt zum Beispiel durch diesen Einsatz von diesen neuen Technologien, die jetzt europaweit generalisiert werden, halt dann sehr einfach zum Beispiel einfach ICEs fahren lassen auf ihrem Gleisbett. Und auch TGVs. Genau, also um dazu zu sagen, dieses LZB-System, das ist nicht europaweit, das ist eine deutsche Sache. Darüber wir vorhin geredet haben, durch diese Beeinflussung. Und da wird jetzt europaweit wohl ein Standard festgelegt, der auch noch nicht ganz durch... ETCS ist glaube ich bis Level 2. Also noch nicht ganz, also das ist ein Detail, aber das ist noch nicht ganz durchspezifiziert und die streiten sich noch und jeder will seine Sachen reinbringen. Das ist noch nicht richtig etabliert, aber es kommt.
Wie heißt der Standard?
Our European Train Control System, ETCS. Und da gibt es dann verschiedene Leveln, die umgesetzt werden sollen. Das endgültige Ziel ist dann, dass das Level 3 erreicht wird, was dann auch wirklich die Abschaffung von Blöcken im Bahnverkehr bedeuten würde und dann hin zu diesen Moving Blocks gehen würde. Dass man also relativ Abstände fahren kann und dann halt keinen Blockverkehr mehr fahren kann. Und das sind auch dann die Standards, wo dann auch GSM-R ins Spiel kommt. Also dieses speziell auf den Zugverkehr zugeschnittene GSM-System. Weil eben keine durchgehende Linie besteht wie im deutschen System, sondern vereinzelte Punkte nur, wo aber mehr Daten in beide Richtungen übertragen werden.
Du redest jetzt von GSM-R?
Nein, über ETCS.
Dann werden wir erst mal da.
Genau. Und wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel stehen bleibt, dann hat man kein... Wie ich unbedingt Daten übertragen wollte, bin ich genau auf dieser Zugangsschritte. Das sind keine Kabel mehr, sondern das ist so eine Balise, die einfach alle 50 bis 100 Meter im Gleisbett drin ist. Das ist halt so mit dem gelben Kopf oben drauf. Und da fährt der Zug rüber und beim Rüberfahren gibts einen Datenaustausch. So und wenn der Zug steht und über nicht keine Balise mehr rüberkommt, dann kriegt er auch keine Weiterfahrtserlaubnis. Und da muss man halt mit anderen Technologien ran, um halt an diesen Zug wieder sagen zu können, hier sind deine Koordinaten, also hier sind meine Koordinaten, schau bitte die aktuelle Situation an, darf ich weiterfahren? Und dann kann man einen Weiterfahrbefehl über GSMR zum Beispiel. Da wird auch das erste Mal das Thema Security dann wirklich richtig interessant. Weil da eben Funk-Übertragung für lebenswichtige Daten.
Ja, GSMR, also das ist sozusagen ein speziell für den Eisenbahneinsatz gedachtes GSM.
Das ist ein GSM mit eigenen Frequenzen, mit Gruppenruf und mit ganz klaren Prioritäten. Also es gibt dann halt Calls, die andere Calls verdrängen können. Ja, ich war da auch schon mal Zeuge eines Telefongesprächs einer Zugchefin. Und sie hat sehr offensichtlich mit mehreren Leuten geredet. Das kann dann irgendwie so ein Broadcast- oder Multicast-Gespräch gewesen sein. Also ganz interessant. Und das System ist jetzt glaube ich auch vorgeschrieben, dass zumindest auch LCB-Strecken danach unterscheiden müssen, auf dieses System jetzt in den nächsten Jahren umgerüstet werden, damit halt gerade dieser europäische Zugaustausch möglich wird.
Aber derzeit ist es so, dass wenn dieser Velaro, also der neuste ICE, also ist das eine ICE 4 oder...
Velaro D, der wird auch unter ICE 3 fahren. Ist ein Dreier. Also so in dem Bahn-Jaggon. Es gibt auch schon verschiedene ICE 3s, aber das ist heiß.
Ja, okay, das ist mehr so eine Plattform. Also das ist sozusagen so ein Modulsystem, was dann in China ein bisschen anders zusammengebaut wurde.
Genau, das wäre jetzt ein Velaro CN, glaube ich. Der einzig große Unterschied beim neuen ICE ist, dass er diesmal wirklich komplett von Siemens kommt und nicht mehr von verschiedenen Firmen zusammen gekauft wurde. Siemens hat das vorher schon hauptsächlich gemacht, hat sich selber umgekümmert, aber der ist jetzt wirklich komplett von Siemens aus einer Hand gebaut worden. Das ist eigentlich so der einzig große Unterschied und halt dann die Vorbereitung auf die neuen, auf die anderen Stromsysteme und viele Kleinigkeiten. Also das bei TGV zum Beispiel auf den französischen Strecken durch den Schotter-Unterbau halt bei hohen Geschwindigkeiten, Steine halt eher von unten gegen den Zug prallen, dass er da extra noch mal gehärtet werden muss. Das ist der TGV schon. In Deutschland fährt man halt auf Beton-Unterbau und so Kleinigkeiten müssen halt auch überall beachtet werden.
Ja, genau.
Es ist halt gerade dieser Prozess sehr gut zu beobachten, dass alles in Europa da sehr stark zusammenwächst. Also Spanien kriegt jetzt immer ein stärkeres, also investieren sehr, sehr viel Geld in ein gutes Schnellfahrnetz, wo auch eben diese Veloros drauf fahren. Italien bindet sich gerade an Frankreich an, die Schweiz baut den angesprochenen Tunnel. Genau. Barcelona nach Frankreich wird ausgebaut. Genau.
Das heißt, es gibt so einen europäischen Masterplan, wie man alle Netze zusammenführt.
Genau. Das wird auch stark subventioniert dann von der EU. Es gibt da sogenannte, magistralen nennen sie das, so Hauptstrecken, die wie eben jetzt Paris, Paris über Wien, Stuttgart, München, Wien bis Budapest dann runtergehen soll. Da wird dann eben investiert, dass diese Strecke verbessert wird. Dann fließen dann eben ein bisschen mehr Gelder. Das ist natürlich nicht, dass sie alles zahlen, aber dass eben das so subventioniert wird und dann es attraktiv wird. In dem Kontext ist auch ein bisschen zu sehen, diese Verbesserung der Strecke zwischen Ulm und Stuttgart.
Das umstrittene Stuttgarter Bahnhofsprojekt.
Nee, das ist, ja, das ist glaube ich auch Bestandteil von dem Gesamt... Die Strecke selber ist glaube ich nicht bestritten, weil die wirklich eine große Fahrzeitersparnis bringt und halt überhaupt erst diese europäische Magistrale, die langlaufen soll, dann erst auf die Paris-München-Zeit von 4 Stunden und 40 Minuten runterdrückt. Aber um das in Fahrplanzeiten auszudrücken, diese Strecke, die bringt eine halbe Stunde. Und dieser Stuttgart 21 bringt so acht Minuten. Das ist dieser Tunnel, da um den geht es, da ist der Streit. Die Strecke ändert so ein bisschen südlich von Stuttgart. Die neu gebaute.
Genau, weil sie derzeit sozusagen durch sehr bergiges Gebiet geht, mit hohen Steigungen und dementsprechend muss dort langsam gefahren werden. Ich weiß nicht, ich hatte irgendwann mal den Mythos gehört, dass schon aber vor einigen Jahren schon mal schnellere Streckengeschwindigkeiten erreicht wurden nach München, als das heute der Fall ist. Oder ist das nicht so?
Vielleicht sprichst du auf die Nürnberg-Ingolstadt-Umfahrung an. Also wenn man jetzt gerade aus Berlin kommt, ist ja...
Ich meine, zwischen Stuttgart und München.
Kann gut sein, dass man Neigetechnik-Züge mal ausrübet hat. Keine Ahnung, das wüsste ich nicht schon. Weiß ich auch nicht. Also es gibt die Gasslinger Steige, das ist halt schon ein ziemlich großer Engpunkt, wo halt hohe Steigungen vorher herrschen und weiß ich auch sonst nichts weiter.
Okay, das heißt, diese Strecke ist sozusagen Teil des europäischen Gesamtplans und soll eine halbe Stunde bringen zwischen Stuttgart und Ulm schon. Oder zwischen Stuttgart und München. Ich meine sozusagen, es ist die halbe Stunde schon bis Ulm gefahren. Das geht dann doppelt so schnell?
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher. Ich weiß jetzt gerade nur, was mich betrifft, das ist halt das... Es waren zwar 22 Minuten, aber es war schon so was. Es war schon erheblich. Und es hat den Vorteil, dass es, glaube ich, wieder auf gerade Zeiten dann in Stuttgart rausläuft. Genau. Und der Zug auf gerade Zeiten in München losfährt. Also dann, um Taktfahrpläne halt dann aufrecht zu erhalten. Das ist auch so ein kleines Thema, diese Fahrgastpsychologie. Das, wann Leute Züge nehmen und wann nicht. Wo man einfach feststellen kann, dass Leute Züge nehmen, wenn sie zu vollen Stunden fahren. Oder zu halben Stunden oder Viertelstunden. Also Sachen, die man sich gut merken kann. Um zur dritten Minute oder zur 23. fahren, dann geht gar nichts mehr. Das ist einfach festzustellen. Und das ist auch so was, weswegen man versucht, wenn man es geschickt macht, wenn man Stadtbahnen oder Busse hat, dass man auch in den Randzeiten regelmäßig in Takt fährt. Obwohl die Fahrzeuge leer bleiben, damit die Leute wissen, dass alle N Minuten das überhaupt fahren. Weil sonst müssen sie auf den Fahrplan gucken, und das wollen sie nicht. Und dann machen sie es irgendwie anders. Und dann noch weiter geht es dann, wenn man dann den integralen Takt-Fahrplan anschaut. Dass man dann versucht, die Fernzüge zu geraden Uhrzeiten einfahren zu lassen. Und dann kurz darum, die Regionalexpresse und Regionalbahnen dann ein bisschen weiter Abstand rumfahren zu lassen. Dass man auch dann diesen Übergang hat von ICE an den Großbahnhöfen zu den Regionalbahnhöfen. Und dann auch dort dann halt den Kunden der Deutschen Bahn halt dann so mitbringen kann. Irgendwie, dass man halt nicht jetzt eine Stunde warten muss, um auf den Regionalexpress zu warten. Also es wird versucht, schon alles so ein bisschen zusammen zu... Natürlich geht das nicht an jedem halt. Das ist logisch. Vor allem, wenn man sich so ein Ruhrgebiet anguckt oder sowas, da geht es natürlich nicht so gut. Aber die Schweiz zum Beispiel wird ja sogar einen integrierten Takt verplant, im Gegensatz dazu. Die haben sogar die Fähre mit eingespannt. Also da ist dann die Fähre mit abgespinkt. Integriert heißt, wenn es intermodal wird. Das heißt, verschiedene Verkehrssysteme aneinander koppelt. Sehr häufig geht das Problem, dass man irgendwie dann im Zug ankommt und fährt kein Bus mehr oder der Bus ist zwei Minuten davor gefahren, weil das nicht aufeinander abgestimmt ist.
Okay, bleiben wir nochmal kurz bei diesem europäischen Netz. Und vielleicht auch nochmal, was weiß ich, diese Stuttgart 21-Geschichte. Ich meine, das ist ja nicht die ganze politische Diskussion, die sich da entfacht hat. Kommentieren oder diskutieren, da fehlt uns jetzt, glaube ich, auch einfach das Grundwissen. Aber nur, um zu verstehen, was sozusagen da der Plan ist. Und vielleicht auch so diese Wechselwirkung, die so ein Kopfbahnhof hat, auf so ein Netz versus eines Durchgangsbahnhofs.
Was wisst ihr darüber? Generell kann man sagen, dass halt so ein Bahnhof natürlich verschiedene Faktoren hat, wie stark er den Durchsatz, was für einen Durchsatz er hinbekommen kann. Und wenn man jetzt natürlich einen Kopfbahnhof hat, wo jetzt Züge mehr oder weniger durchgangsverkehr fahren, ist es natürlich so, dass ein Zug, der von Norden kommt, auf irgendeinen Gleis geschickt wird. Und beim Überfahren von den anderen Gleisen des Bahnhofs... Wenn er nach Süden wieder raus will, muss er alle Gleise überfahren? Muss er einmal alle Gleisen überfahren, muss er auf der anderen Seite wieder raus. Dabei, wie wir durch diesen Blockverkehr gelernt haben, werden alle Gleisen einmal gesperrt. Und je nachdem, wie groß diese Blöcke sind, ist es dann auch schon eine richtig große Auffahrt. Das heißt, so ein Bahnhof kann durch so einen reinkommenden Querschläger ICE für ein paar Minuten erst mal außer Gefecht gesetzt sein. Vor allem bei einem Kopfbahnhof wissen wir ja auch, dass wir da mit irgendwie 20 kmh oder so was gegen Ende reinfahren. Das heißt, man kann nicht irgendwie mit 70 kmh reinfahren und dann stark bremsen, sondern da wird richtig langsam reingefahren. Also das Anfahrtsgebiet ist auch schon auf 40 kmh meistens runtergebremst. Weil da die ganzen Weichen da liegen und die Weichen sind teuer. Also Kopfbahn billige Weichen, die nicht so schnelle Geschwindigkeiten haben. Also ist alles so ein bisschen tricky. Und deswegen hat man halt angefangen, Überschlag-Bauwerke zu bauen, die quasi einfach... Überwurf-Bauwerke zu bauen, die die Weichen einfach mal von der südlichen Seite auf die nördliche Seite zum Beispiel katapultieren, ohne jetzt den komplett anderen Bahnverkehr zu beeinflussen. Überwurf heißt einfach, dass wir Gleise haben, die einmal über eine Brücke auf die andere Seite geführt werden, was auch extrem teuer ist, weil Züge sehr schwer sind. Genau, also das ist auch entsprechend teuer.
Das ist auch ein Stuttgarter Fall zum Beispiel.
Das fängt ja schon weit, weit 20 Kilometer fast schon vor Stuttgart an, wo er versucht wird, diese Gleisen so zu sortieren, dass sie halt möglichst gut in den Bahnhof reinkommen. Genau, das ist halt auch so, dass es wird ja auch, wenn dieser Bau durchgeführt wird, wird ja auch sehr viel Platz frei. Sieht man ja, wie viele Hektar das überhaupt sind, durch dieses Vorfeldfall. Und wenn man jetzt sagen würde, man würde eine Bresche schneiden durch den Rest von Stuttgart und das überirdisch fahren lassen, würde trotzdem so viel frei werden. Weil es liegt nicht daran, dass es unterirdisch ist plötzlich das Ganze, sondern einfach weil man viel weniger Weichen braucht.
Weil einfach der Kopfbahnhof so viel aufnimmt.
Und Weichen sind halt auch sehr teuer. Die haben sehr großen Verschleiß und die Wartungen. Die müssen beheizt werden und so weiter im Winter. Also es ist alles nicht so, viele Signale braucht man. Das ist eine teure Sache.
Das heißt, ein Durchgangsbahnhof ist allein schon deshalb, also jetzt aus Sicht der Bahn, schon deshalb interessant, weil es sich einfach als Bahnhof billiger und einfacher betreiben lässt.
Absolut.
Und so für den Durchsatz?
Durchsatz auch ganz extrem. Man kann auf viel weniger Gleise viel mehr das Gleiche liefern. Also ich denke mal, dass auf mindestens, ich meine, sonst würden sie ja nicht neu bauen, mindestens halt die aktuellen 16 Gleisen jetzt auf acht Gleisen gepresst werden können. Das heißt also, da muss schon irgendwie schon eine Relation vorhanden sein. Also das ist, genau, das ist schon ein sehr starker Unterschied.
Aber ihr seid jetzt mit den Plänen so nicht vertraut.
Es ist auch irgendwie, wir haben es versucht, so ein bisschen wirklich mal reinzugucken. Also bis auf die Prognosen, die halt so in Aussicht gestellt wurden, wie viele Züge jetzt zum Beispiel bestimmte Strecken fahren werden, ist es da relativ schwer, irgendwie einen Überblick zu bekommen. Da fehlt uns auch selber das Wissen so viel. Man kriegt die Daten auch kaum. Also wir haben ein bisschen geschaut, man kriegt so ein Planfestungsverfahren, aber nicht irgendwie die Gutachten dazu oder... Das ist alles nicht ganz so transparent.
Jaja, das ist ja glaube ich auch der Mittelpunkt.
Dadurch ist es halt auch sehr schwer zu bewerten. Also generell kann man sagen, dass ein Durchgangsbahnhof wesentlich höhere Kapazitäten zulässt als die Kopfbahnhöfe. Genau, deswegen werden ja auch keine Kopfbahnhöfe mehr gebaut. Das waren ja früher Prestigeobjekte der Stadt, die halt in der Mitte der Stadt sind, prunkvoll. Leipzig zum Beispiel, das ist einfach eine Sache, da ist einfach die Stadtverschönerung damit auch irgendwie... Wenn man sich jetzt mal Riesenstädte anguckt, wie Paris und London, wo man mehrere Bahnhöfe hat, da ist es eine Katastrophe, da den Zug zu wechseln. Wenn man jetzt irgendwie aus Karlsruhe kommt und dann nach London weiterfahren will, dann muss man vom östlichen Bahnhof zum nördlichen. Dazwischen halt mit der Metro. Das ist nicht so schön alles insgesamt, wenn man viel Gepäck hat und so. Das ist ja das, was die beiden ja gerade bekämpfen möchte. Genau. Das hat sie bislang auch in den meisten Fällen... Zum Beispiel in Berlin hat man ja einen Turmbahnhof sogar, das ist eine sehr eindrucksvolle Sache. Das heißt, dass auf verschiedenen Ebenen Züge in verschiedene Richtungen sich kreuzen. Das gibt es ja mehrfach in Berlin. Und man gibt da verschiedene Formen, dass man die Gleise entheddert quasi. Dass man eben versucht, diese Vorfeldproblematik zu lösen.
Das heißt, die Kunst liegt wirklich da drin... Ja, man muss sozusagen global denken. Also jetzt nicht nur global, nicht der ganze Planet, sondern wenn man sozusagen sein Netz anschaut, da die Kapazitäten voranzutreiben, ist ein sehr diffiziles Zusammenspiel von extrem vielen Komponenten.
Man muss auch... Demografie muss man alleine... Wie entwickelt sich das Ganze? Reicht das jetzt mit unseren Zweitunnelröhren, die wir da haben?
Aber wie steht denn Deutschland zum Beispiel da? Also die Schweiz wird immer gerne gelobt für ihr Eisenbahnnetz, was sehr umfangreich ist und wohl auch sehr pünktlich. Wie bewertet ihr denn sozusagen den Ist-Zustand?
Das ist extrem gut. Ja, das ist auch führend auf jeden Fall.
Woran macht ihr das fest?
An der Transportmenge am Passagieren ist das eine. An der durchschnittlichen Pünktlichkeit ist es natürlich immer schwierig, zu bewerten, wie das gemessen wird und so weiter. Technologie fördert oder Technologie treibt vor allem, was für Züge fahren. Wenn man sich zum Beispiel einfach so die Baureihen anschaut oder wenn man sich anschaut, auch dann bei den Hochgeschwindigkeitszügen TGV versus ICE, kann man ja jetzt auch über die schnellste, höchste Geschwindigkeit reden oder einfach über Fahrkomfort und so Sachen. Und meinem Eindruck ist auch der ICE da schon ein bisschen besser. Aber ändert sich halt auch wieder von Jahr zu Jahr, klar. Aber sie sind halt einfach im Vorderfeld, im Spitzenfeld. Ja, und dann auch die Anbindung der Städte. Was für mich immer ein guter Messpunkt ist, ist, wie ist der Flugverkehr innerhalb des Landes? Das ist, finde ich, eigentlich... Weil das Auto als Konkurrenz zu bemessen, ist immer recht schwierig. Aber am Flugverkehr kann man es ganz gut festhalten. In Deutschland ist der Flugverkehr zwischen manchen Städten existent, z.B. München, Hamburg. Weil das ist nicht so einfach. Da wird alles dran gearbeitet. Auch wie eine sehr umschrittene Baustelle, anderes Thema. Aber man versucht diese Fahrzeit zu verkürzen. Aber man hat ab einer gewissen räumlichen Entfernung ist es schwierig, gegen Flugverkehr anzukommen mit der Schiene. Ein anderes Beispiel ist Paris London. Da ist kaum noch Flugverkehr da. Es gibt es noch wenig, aber es ist unglaublich produziert worden. Der Zug hätte schon ordentlich runtergefahren. Innerhalb von Frankreich gibt es auch nicht mehr viel. Nur noch die Diagonal-Wilke.
Durch die TGV-Verbindung.
Das war auch ganz klar das Ziel von ihnen. Es gibt Länder, wo es nicht so einfach ist. Aber wenn man Richtentfernung nimmt, wenn man sich überlegt, man nimmt die Entfernung von 500, 600 km als Richtwert und man sieht, dass der Flugverkehr keine Chance hat, dann ist das ein Zeichen, dass das Netz ganz gut ist. Das ist meine persönliche Interpretation. Das würde ich auch gerne zustimmen. Aber man muss halt irgendwas als Indikator nehmen.
Jetzt haben wir natürlich extrem immer diese Personenverkehr-Perspektive eingenommen bisher. Der Güterverkehr spielt ja auch eine große Rolle.
Wahrscheinlich sogar die größere. Vielleicht ist es schwierig zu sagen. Das ist immer die Frage, wie man sieht. Von Infrastruktur-Aufgaben-Bereich ist natürlich der Personenverkehr vorrangig, wenn man es aus Staatssicht sieht. Aber aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht sieht es schon ein bisschen anders aus. Da ist Güterverkehr, vor allem der Verkehr von produzierenden Industrie zum Hafen hin. In Deutschland ist das ein sehr ernsthandes Thema. Da würde die Bahn sehr gerne tagsüber die ICs halten lassen und die Güterzüge mit voller Autos durchlassen. Nachts gibt es dann auch wirklich Geschifte von den Prioritäten. Da sind die Güterzüge doch ein bisschen mehr Prioritäten. Die haben definitiv absoluten Vorrang in der Nacht und tagsüber haben die Personenzüge absoluten Vorrang. Das stört die Bahn da so ein bisschen. Die Bahn hat auch Studien. Was kostet sie eine Minute Verspätung? Was kostet sie ein frustrierter Passagier? Wenn man es aufrechnet, lohnt es sich, trotzdem den Zug mit den Autos durchzulassen. Vor allem, wenn es zum Teil Just-In-Time-Verkehr ist und dann auch bestimmte SLAs. Sie garantieren bestimmte Anlieferungszeiten. Ja, aus der IT eigentlich, so dieser Begriff. Die Motor müssen da sein, wenn die Karosserien bereitstehen, dass die Motoren angebaut werden können. Da gibt es dann einfach Züge, die müssen einfach durch und werden entsprechend hoch behandelt. Die werfen vor allem dann richtig Schotter ab für die Bahn. Alle, die volle Züge beladen kriegen, benutzen die Bahn sehr gerne. Also auch Kohle, Transport und sowas. Es schüttet gut aller Art. Einzelverkehr, wo man nur so Lkw-Größen hat. Es gibt schon stammgestellte Züge, aber es ist weniger der Fall. Es gibt ja die rollende Landstraße, wo sich das ein bisschen vertreten kann. Das sind alles Pilotprojekte, wo Lkw auf Züge fahren. Da ist es schwierig, dem Lkw-Verkehr den Rang abzulaufen. Interessant wird es, wenn man das wieder auf höherer Ebene sieht, und den richtigen Langstreckenverkehr. Und da versucht die Schifffahrt zu attackieren. Die Russen bauen nämlich ihre transsibirische Eisenbahn immer weiter aus und verbessern den Streckenzustand zunehmend. Wir haben vor Kurzem alles zweigleisig gemacht. Es wurden ein paar Brücken erneuert. Da ist es eine ewig lange Strecke und der Etat ist auch begrenzt. Eigentlich gibt es in der Russischen Eisenbahn ziemlich gut. Das ist auf die Streckenlänge gemessen. Das ist schon ein Problem. Es fehlt häufig sehr langsam gefahren, etwa 50 kmh oder so etwas. Interessant ist, dass es da eine durchgehende Schienenverbindung zwischen China und Westeuropa gibt. Das ist von der Fahrt her ein enormer Unterschied zum Schiffferkehr. Das kann trotzdem noch eine Woche sein, aber es ist wahrscheinlich die Hälfte zum Schiffferkehr. Die großen Containerschiffe kommen nicht durch den Suez-Kanal durch. Die müssen ja außenrum über Afrika geroutet werden. Da kann die Bahn dann durchaus punkten. Sachen, die in Schiffen liegen, sind einfach totes Kapital. Das ist ein Thema, das interessant werden kann.
Das wird schon gemacht?
Das gibt es schon, aber es ist noch nicht so. Es ist definitiv ausbaufähig und sehr interessant. Was gibt es noch? Die Japaner haben sehr starkes Interesse, ans Festland gekoppelt zu werden. Sie haben in ihrer Inseln die Großen miteinander verbunden mit Tunneln. Sie haben zwei Möglichkeiten, sich ans Festland anzubinden. Sie haben große Interessen, sich seit Ewigkeiten an Südkorea zu binden. Das wäre ein Monster-Tunnel mit 200 Kilometer Länge. Ein 209 Kilometer langer Tunnel wäre das.
209 Kilometer.
Zwischendrin gibt es Inseln.
Wie lang ist dieser Gotthalt-Tunnel, der gerade gebaut wurde?
Der Ärmelkanal-Tunnel ist auch nur 50 Kilometer.
Also nicht im Ansatz.
Nein, das Projekt ist schon länger. Als sie gehört haben, dass dieser Ärmelkanal und diese ganzen anderen Sachen kamen, haben sie es erst mal gewartet und geguckt, wie die Erfahrungen da sind. Sie haben auch noch ganz andere Problemstellungen. Sie haben Erdbeben und so weiter. Aber das Interesse ist sehr groß und sie haben da Konsortien gegründet. Das ist ein sehr langsamer Prozess und wahrscheinlich dauert es auch noch lange. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine Diskussion. Die andere Möglichkeit wären auf die Insel Sachalin, die nördlich Japans liegt, eine russische Insel. Das wären irgendwie, ich weiß gar nicht, 40 Kilometer. War nicht so dramatisch. Von der Insel zum Festland ist es sehr kurz, sind so 10 Kilometer noch. Da gibt es auch schon Vorbereitungen, die damals unter Stalin... Da haben Zwangsarbeiter schon angefangen zu graben. Aber dann hat Stalin tot, weil er haben sie aufgehört. Und da könnte man auch relativ leicht den Anschluss an die transsibirische Eisenbahn herstellen. Und damit an Europa auch. In Südkorea wäre es wohl erst mal nur in Südkorea, als in Nordkorea noch im Weg ist.
Na gut, Japan und Südkorea liegen sich ja im Prinzip direkt gegenüber. Das bietet sich ja an.
Auch wirtschaftlich interessant. Die Eisenbahn wird halt auch langsam zu einer globalen Komponente, die interessant ist. Nicht nur auf EU-Ebene, auch nicht auf Landesebene, sondern wirklich. Ja, und dann hat man auch im Gespräch gehabt, ob man die Beringsee überwindet. Und dann eine direkte Trasse zwischen Alaska und Russland. Also ein bisschen Wunschdenken, weil da natürlich überhaupt keine Infrastruktur rundherum vorhanden ist.
Da muss man auch erst mal riesige Trassen durchs Land bauen.
Ja, vor allem in Russland eben. Aber es gibt da schon interessante Ideen. Oder unter Gibraltar durch, wo aber auch zwei Platten aufeinandertreffen, das ist noch nicht so einfach. Aber es ist halt alles technisch nicht unmöglich.
Mittlerweile hat die Eisenbahn Auftrieb.
Das merkt man ja. Also auch in Amerika wird dran gearbeitet. Genau, die haben ihre Konjunkturförder. Genau, im Westen werden neue Strecken gebaut. Laut der Kleinigkeiten passieren das schon. Die haben wir in Amerika. Die sind eigentlich immer relativ eisenbahnenarm gewesen. Also Langstrecken, Güterschwergüterzüge, auf schlecht gewarteten Strecken. So ein Bild, das man hat eigentlich. Sie haben einen schnellen Zug, der Nord-Ost-Channel, zwischen New York und Boston fährt da was. Also es ist nichts besonders Großes. Und dann wollen sie halt an der Westküste, Seattle, Vancouver. Das ist einfach sehr interessant.
Aber der, glaube ich, Internet anbaut.
Der Aesla Express, kann sein. Er ist halt mehr wie Fliegen. Man bucht da ewig im Voraus, hat sehr hohe Preise. Man kann gar nicht einfach in den Bahnhof gehen und sich ein Ticket kaufen. Die Preise bei diesem Schnellzug sind andere Welten.
Das Thema vielleicht nochmal hier. Internet im Zug. Wisst ihr was da drüber?
Sie haben ja diese WLAN-Access-Points. Das ist auch rentlich, glaube ich. Ich weiß nicht, ob das UMTS geht. Das ist WiMAX. Das kann auch gut sein. Aber es hat eine Reichweite von 50 Kilometern. Ob man das dann an ganzen Strecken hat, kann gut sein. WiMAX ist wahrscheinlich streckenabhängig. Dann haben sie wahrscheinlich an die Strecken ihre Access-Points geflanscht.
Das ist schon eine spezielle Infrastruktur. Das hat Vor- und Nachteile. Auf der einen Seite ist man natürlich super schnell unterwegs. Mit so einem Zug, das macht es jetzt erstmal nicht einfach. Aber dafür weiß man ja eigentlich vorher schon, wo der Zug ist. Es ist sehr vorhersagbar, wie schnell er sich bewegt. Oder sogar auch in der Echtzeit messbar. Sodass man ja solche Funkstrecken optimieren kann. Diese Laufzeitproblematik etc. muss man zwar berücksichtigen. Aber man sieht es halt. Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht sehr viel mehr, als dass da vermutlich WiMAX am Start ist. Und dann im Zug wird es mit WLAN weiter verteilt. Aber der Zug, der von Köln nach Frankreich... Genau, der Thalys-Zug. Der hat ja serienmäßig Internet an Bord. Also wenn man da First Class-Ticket hat, dann ist das sozusagen auch inklusive. In Schweden auch so. Da muss man irgendwie noch mal ein bisschen dazu. Das finde ich jetzt auch etwas, was das Zugfahren...
Ja, das ist...
Das finde ich noch mal besonders interessant macht. Jetzt rede ich hier auch einfach mal als Chaosradio Express im Intercity Express. Das ist so... Das ist eigentlich das Schöne am Zugfahren, dass man da einfach immer noch aktiv sein kann. Da gehört natürlich heute Netz dazu. Und das fehlt irgendwie in Deutschland.
Ja, das ist natürlich die negative Seite, von dem die Uhren ticken bei der Bahn etwas langsamer.
Schon was mit den Steckdosen hat lange gedauert.
Ich meine, wenn man ICE2 fährt, hat man immer noch... Die haben ja noch die alte Innenausstattung. Die Staubsaugersteckdosen funktionieren häufig. Die missbrauchen, genau. Ja, das ist natürlich ein Problem. In Nordrhein-Westfalen bin ich letztens Zuggefahren mit so einer Privatgesellschaft. Und die hatten Steckdosen am Platz schon in einem Regionalzug. Also, ja, das dauert eine Weile, bis sich das etabliert. Die müssen dann komplett auf alle Züge eine neue Innenausstattung ausrollen, die dann erst mal designt wird von irgendjemandem. Da muss es zertifiziert werden. Das ist sowieso ein Problem bei der Bahn. Viele Sachen sind deswegen teuer, weil sie zertifiziert werden müssen. Bis es dann wirklich weitfällt. Das ist nicht so einfach, aber das stimmt schon. Komfortfragen ist natürlich ein anderes Thema. Technisch könnte man auch schon wesentlich weiter sein. Bis hin, dass man schon während der Fahrt koppeln könnte, um sich die Züge, die CE3 zwischen Frankfurt und Köln, sich einen Kopp hinlassen könnten. Eine Garnitur geht direkt woanders hin. Das wäre technisch wahrscheinlich schon möglich.
In der freien Fahrt.
In der vollen Fahrt, ja. Das wäre technisch wahrscheinlich gut möglich. Aber es ist halt eine Zertifizierungs-Sache. Das ist das erste Mal im Bundesamt. Das zeigt den halt dann den Vogel.
Aber wenn es alles immer so viel Vorlauf hat, dann müsste man sich auch schon ganz gut ablesen können, was die nächsten großen Entwicklungen sind, die eintreffen werden, weil sie schon seit Langem geplant werden.
Das ist immer so das Problem mit der Transparenz. Dass man sich schon sehr detailliert damit beschäftigen muss und genau wissen muss, wo man schauen muss. Das eine ist auf jeden Fall das ECTS mit dem Moving Blocksgas. Aber man kriegt das dann schon raus. Die Bahn hat jetzt zum Beispiel Ersatz für die InterCities bestellt. Und für IC1 glaube ich auch. Gleichzeitig soll es die beiden ersetzen. Das ist das ICX-Projekt. Das heißt, dass die InterCities auch durch so Triebzüge ersetzt werden, die eben nicht so schnell fahren. Die Lok ist mehr oder weniger, kommt ein Integrit vor in den kompletten... Ja genau, das ist genauso wie beim IC3, nur halt ein bisschen kleiner. Davon haben sie mal einen großen Satz bestellt. Kleiner?
Also die sind nicht so schnell oder was?
Die sind nicht so schnell und sie haben auch nicht die Passagierkapazität, weil es einfach für die Nebenstrecken gedacht ist. Weil der IC endlich mal selbst werden muss. Die Waggons, die man da hat, die sind so alt mittlerweile. Es erinnert sich immer an die Innenausstattung, alle 15 Jahre, aber nichtsdestotrotz ist das immer noch sehr altes Rollmaterial. Also auch mal neue Steckdosen rein. Das merkt man ja immer. Man denkt dann immer, man hat einen neuen Zug vor sich, wenn die Innenausstattung anders ist.
Und da tut sich trassentechnisch noch eine Menge. Es gibt ja so ein paar Städte, die sind immer noch verdammt schlecht angebunden. Von Berlin nach Dresden fahren, das ist eine echte Zubutung.
Da fehlt ja vor allem noch, glaube ich, die Strecke von Leipzig-Dresden, die ja ausgebaut werden muss.
Also von Leipzig nach Dresden ist eine geplant?
Nee, die denke ich muss ausgebaut werden. Da ist mir aber gerade nichts bekannt, was passieren müsste. Also es gibt halt die Projekte, die gerade im Bau sind natürlich. Das im Osten, dass die Fahrzeit zwischen Berlin und München gekürzt wird. Das ist dieses Projekt, das auch viel kritisiert ist, weil die Meistzeit der Zug im Tunnel oder auf Brücken ist. Und dann natürlich hier bei Ulm. Dann habe ich letztens zufällig im Rahmen eines Projektes eine Diskussion dazu gesehen, dass die Strecke zwischen Mannheim und Frankfurt entlastet werden soll. Das ist eine Parallel-Strecke auf der anderen Rheinseite, weil die ist sehr überlastet. Frankfurt hat vor allem Kapazität-Probleme im Bahnhofseinfahrbereich durch die Rheinbrücken, die den Zugverkehr auf ein paar wenige Stellen bündelt.
Das ist gar nicht so sehr wegen des Kopfbahnhofs.
Wahrscheinlich auch, aber ich denke, dass von Süden her die Züge schon durch Ost-Lingendruck stehen. Genau, die aus Frankfurt-Flughafen kommen noch dazu vor Mannheim. Das ist eine sehr enge Sache, die Strecke da. Da gibt es auch noch eine Kurve, die sehr langsam ist. Ich weiß gerade den Namen nicht. Deswegen wird auf der anderen Seite noch eine Strecke wohlgebaut. Das ist natürlich immer eine sehr lange Sache. Da am Stadt konnte sich lange nicht einigen, ob sie den alten Bahnhof weiter nutzen wollen oder einen außerhalb wollen. Natürlich wollen sie den alten Bahnhof weiter benutzen, aber Lärmschutz usw. ist ganz schwierig. Und jede Legislaturperiode ist dann wieder ein anderer Wunsch da. Und so was zieht sich halt, diese ganzen Planverfahren und so was, es zieht sich ewig hin. Aber wenn man das mal ein bisschen beobachtet, dann sieht man so, was grob in Planung ist, aber das dauert natürlich. Also ich denke, München, Berlin und München, Stuttgart, sind gerade so die wichtigsten Entwicklungen. Was noch sehr interessant zu beobachten sein wird, ist, was Großbritannien dann demnächst macht, weil es kann ja auch nicht so weitergehen mit ihrem recht alten Netz. 200 km Höchstgeschwindigkeit.
Bislang kommt man gut rein. Haben Sie das mittlerweile eingesehen?
Das ist schon lange bekannt, aber Sie wollen halt kein Geld investieren eigentlich. Das ist das Problem. Und privat macht das niemand. Also ich meine, Fernverkehr ist eine rentable Sache. Regionale Verkehr ist eine Verlustsache. Regionale Verkehr ist eine Verlustsache. Es ist natürlich immer noch die Frage, ob es irgendwo auf der Welt wirklich stattfindet, dass auch die Infrastruktur und Fernverkehr, also das Fernverkehr auf der eigenen Infrastruktur, immer noch rentabel ist. Das Problem ist halt, volkswirtschaftlich ist das sehr rentabel. Aber ob es eine Firma schafft, irgendwie auf 30 Jahre im Voraus zu investieren und dann erst ihre Gewinne zu machen und dann so zu überleben, das will ich erst mal sehen. Also das ist halt die Schwierigkeit, dass das schwierig privatwirtschaftlich umzusetzen ist.
Das heißt, der Privatisierung der Bahn steht dir da auch eher skeptisch gegenüber?
Nee, die funktioniert eigentlich quasi nicht. Also man muss halt schon Subventionen tätigen, um halt das Gleisnetz am Leben zu erhalten. Das ist einfach so. Das ist wie beim Autoverkehr. Die Straßen müssen halt auch irgendwo herkommen. Das ist halt auch der Steuerzahler.
Die Frage, ob jetzt sozusagen die Bahnlinien, die sozusagen fahren, und das, was das Netz betreibt, ob es das wirklich dasselbe sein muss.
Das sind es ja auch genau nicht. Das DB Netz ist ja das eine und das andere ist DB-Fertverkehr und DB-Regio. DB-Fertverkehr ist profitabel und das funktioniert auch gut. Aber natürlich sind da die Zahlen von DB Netz nicht mit drin. Ich weiß nicht, wie das bei denen aussieht. Der DB Netz ist ja eigentlich dann schon stark subventioniert. Da läuft es eigentlich fast Richtung starker staatlicher Kontrolle raus. Der greift dann auch natürlich das Eisenbahnbundesamt ein und schaut nach, wie werden dann auch die Strecken vergeben. Also es dürfen ja auch andere Eisenbahnverkehrsbetriebe betreiben. Das ist die Netzregierungsbehörde, die das macht. Das ist auf jeden Fall, weiß ich gerade nicht sicher. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine Regulierungsbehörde, die das halt kontrolliert. Dass halt auch andere Eisenbahnverkehrsgesellschaften Verkehrsbetriebe drauf fahren können. Und dass halt auch das gerecht vermietet werden kann oder halt ersteigert werden kann, je nachdem, wie halt dann die Verfahren sind. Es gibt da so Ausschreibungen für Strecken. Man wird bevorzugt behandelt, wenn man schon die Strecke vorher hatte. Also natürlich ist ihnen auch klar, dass man bestimmte Sachen halt, damit es Gewinn bringt, es so machen muss. Das heißt, sie haben nicht irgendwie so ein knallter Schema. Aber man muss halt bestimmte Parameter haben. Sie sind halt auf jeden Fall im Blick, dass halt nicht irgendwie einen ganzen Tag irgendwie die Strecke der deutschen Bahn-Nutzung zur Verfügung steht oder dass Schenker sich komplette Teile kauft, die sie nur ein Jahr rund um die Uhr fahren können. Genau, also zum Beispiel im Nahverkehr ist klassisch immer Verlustgeschäft. Da wird festgelegt, Dorf XY muss täglich so und so oft angefahren werden. Dafür kriegt ihr auch das Geld? Dann gibt es subventioniert, das macht das Land dann, um der Infrastrukturaufgabe gerecht zu werden, dass die Leute da auch in die Stadt können. Und die Betreibergesellschaft kassiert dann die Subventionen und noch was reinkommt an Umsetzen, was dann eben nicht so viel ist. Sprich, in vielen Bundesländern ist es dann ziemlich Katastrophe. Ich weiß das von Leuten, die ich in Nordrhein-Westfalen kenne, dass die sehr unzufrieden mit der Bahn im Allgemeinen sind und am liebsten gar keinen Zug fahren würden, weil es sich so entwickelt hat, dass die Bahn eigentlich gar kein großes Interesse hat, die Leute gut zu transportieren, weil es gar nicht darum geht. Man muss die Leute nicht zufriedenstellen, um das Geld zu verdienen. Oder man will einfach nur Konkurrenz aus dem Markt halten. Genau, die Bahn zahlt dann auch gerne mal drauf, damit keine Konkurrenz reinkommt.
In dem Moment, wo es Konkurrenz gäbe, könnte das auf einmal ganz anders sein.
In Nordrhein-Westfalen hat die Bahn viele Strecken verloren. Die anderen legen schon Wert auf Kundenzufriedenheit. So wie ich das bislang beurteilen kann.
Und auch auf Gewinn. Warum sollte man es sonst machen?
Natürlich, das wird schon laufen.
Es ist nicht per se so, dass man da kein Geld verdienen könnte. Sonst würde da wohl kaum Mitbewerber auf den Markt drängen.
Aber die verdienen nur Geld durch die Subvention. Es ist ganz schwierig im Regionalverkehr, ohne Subvention Geld zu verdienen. Ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass es auch Firmen gibt, wie die Vogtlandbahn. Wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass die von Bahnnetz auch gegründet wurde, weil sie gerne Bahn fahren.
Dass früher so was hochgekommen ist.
Ja, nicht ganz. Aber das waren auf jeden Fall auch von Bahninteressierten. Es ist dann nicht so weit weg. Häufig stecken in diesen ganzen privaten Gesellschaften auch wieder irgendwelche Städte dahinter, die unzufrieden waren mit den Leistungen, die von der Bahn kamen und so weiter. Es ist halt, oder irgendwelche Kommunen und so weiter, dass es häufig gar nicht so privat ist, wie man sich das vorstellt. Und in den Ländern, wo es dann eigentlich wahrscheinlich gar nicht so privat ist, wir hatten lustige Beispiele in Mexiko, wo halt der Start wahrscheinlich einfach gar keine Mitwirkung hat. Im Eisenbahnverkehr passen dann die komischsten Sachen. Also wir haben dann Flüssiggas-Züge mitten durch die Innenstadtrollen sehen. Also in Google Maps kann man das da sehr schön anschauen.
Flüssiggas-Züge, meinst du, die Flüssiggas geladen haben?
Genau, Flüssiggas geladene Züge, zu 7,50 Meter mindestens waren das ja. Ja, eher länger. Fahren halt einfach durch die Innenstadt. Ohne Absicherung, ohne Signale. Einfach über die Straße, quer über eine Kreuzung. Das war so das andere Extrem. Da gibt es wahrscheinlich auch keinen Personenverkehr. Also haben wir eigentlich auch nicht so großes... Es waren so Bahnhöfe da, aber die wurden nicht mehr benutzt. Die waren voller... Es ist halt das Schwierige, dass es eigentlich eine Staatsaufgabe ist, für diese Infrastruktur zu sorgen. Ich meine, das ist einfach ein endloses Thema. Das gibt es in allen Bereichen da. Autobahnen ist ja das Gleiche. Man kann ja Mount-Autobahn machen. Wie weit muss der Start der Einfluss haben und so weiter? Es ist halt einfach schwierig, da die Privatisierung korrekt durchzuführen.
Ja, Jungs, für mich steht jetzt auch bald nochmal die Bahn an. Ich nehme dann ja immer ganz gerne den Nachtzug. So einen...
Solang es nicht die Sitzwagen sind.
Nee, nee, französischer Nachtzug. Ich liebe ja den Nachtzug. Ich finde das Konzept einfach ganz großartig. In der jeweiligen Ausprägung muss man natürlich immer gucken.
Ich meine, man kann sich eine Hotelübernachtung sparen.
Ja, man merkt halt die Reise nicht. Und es ist vor allem auch für lange Strecken einfach super. Und auch irgendwie cooler. Und ich mag irgendwie auch dieses Patum-Patum. Das macht einen immer auch ganz romantisch. Grundsätzlich muss ich feststellen, wenn ich mir so überlege, wie das noch in den 80er-Jahren mit der Deutschen Bundesbahn so war im Vergleich der Qualität der ganzen Züge etc., mit jetzigen Zustandsvergleichen, da tut sich doch schon eigentlich eine ganze Menge.
Ja, aber damals wurden auch schon die Weichen gestellt für die aktuelle Entwicklung. Die ganzen Planverfahren für die Sachen, die jetzt gebaut wurden, die kamen schon noch aus der Zeit.
Ja, oder die hat man natürlich als Mitfahrer erst mal nicht bemerkt.
Also das Problem war halt, was in den 60er-Jahren passiert ist. Also das hat sich dann in den 80er-Jahren, wo das Netz immer immer maroder und maroder wurde. Und erst da wurde es dann eingeleitet. Also das ist immer so ein bisschen, dass es nicht so was in Legislaturperioden einzubetten ist.
Dann hoffe ich mal, dass Sie jetzt schon mal irgendwie die Internet- und vor allem die Steckdosenversorgung nachzügen auch schon für die nächsten 20 Jahre angepeilt haben. Eigentlich vielleicht auch nochmal Wasser davon. Jungs, jetzt müssen wir hier mal Schluss machen. Vielen Dank für die ausführliche Darstellung hier von zahlreichen Details. Ich meine, das ist jetzt mal wirklich wieder so ein Thema, wo mir schon vorher klar war, da können wir jetzt 5 Stunden reden. Es gibt immer noch diverse Gesprächsthemenkarten, die man hier so ziehen kann. Aber erst mal als Überblick über, wie denn das alles so zusammenhängt und wie viel vor allem die Sicherheitstechnik funktioniert und welche Bedeutung diese im Bahnbetrieb hat, war das auf jeden Fall schon mal ein sehr interessanter Einblick. Mal gucken, ob sich hier irgendwas Einzelnes nochmal anbietet zur Vertiefung, dann können wir das sicherlich auch nochmal machen. Aber jetzt mache ich erst mal den Deckel zu. Und ja, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Und das war's, Chaosradio Express 171. Die Eisenbahn, die fällt jetzt weg. Und tschüss und bis bald.